Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Doki Bug is back!
Okay, before we begin, I really need to show you guys this really funny comment that I got today, or last night, on my sponsored video of me playing that Sonic Racing game.
I deleted the comment, but like, because I was like, I ain't having that on my channel, but it's actually...
Okay, I'm sorry, like, I know I shouldn't shame them, but, like, if you're, you're the one that posted this comment on my channel.
I am allowed to shame you after that.
You consented now because you put yourself there, even though the comment is deleted.
All right, no, okay, I have to show this.
Okay, here you go.
Fake fan Basic influencer aura Is showing Not in nearly enough Sonic games have been played Yes, that's why That was a sponsored video Not pre Grand Prix For Grand Prix The Yakuza guy There's so many Yakuza guys She didn't even bother to say bad or kazuga this because i've never played yakuza what do you
wait i've never even played yakuza like you guys i don't know what the yakuza guy's name is um greatest crossover since ha ha ha um avengers infinity war i'm just saying if i say the yakuza guy and Everyone knows exactly what Yakuza guy is.
Like who he is.
Everyone knows.
Sega's Davis.
I don't know what that is referring to.
Oh, she saw that meme, but hasn't even seen Sonic Prime, which also has characters from that show in the game, too.
Skateboards?
They're not skateboards.
They don't even have wheels underneath them.
They are hover AirPods.
boards also called in the sonic previous uh lore extreme gear so think like marty mcfly this ain't the new skate board game although tricks can still be performed in the air coins their rings too many mario games played hmm to be fair that i would give him that i i i my mind just automatically went to coins because it's just a it's just a default fucking currency in so many games so of course i went with coins because my brain defaulted to that um girl hasn't even been aware of the previous sonic rider series that probably featured the babylon who the fuck i still don't know who the fuck the babylon rouge are wow what an i was sponsored what do you mean i played three sonic games my entire life and it was I don't remember Sonic Sonic Sonic X DX was it the X Sonic DX um Sonic the newest Sonic game and then uh and the one where we were like filming filming a porno uh Sonic Adventure you know the um The banned Sonic game.
Remember that one?
The one that got banned?
Yeah.
It's Sonic Dreams.
I've only played three Sonic games.
Sonic Dream Collection.
Sad X.
And...
Wait, what was the third one that I named?
Are you freaking...
Oh, the newest one.
The one before the racing one.
One I can't believe.
I'm kidding.
Other than those mistakes.
video was okay I had to share this I removed the comment because I feel like I know a lot of you guys were gonna reply to this I just removed it but I had to show it I was like they commented on my video okay so I'm allowed to show it they will they actually type this up I was like this has to be satire but I don't think so I don't because like son because sonic fans are actually like this so i know it's not satire
this is someone that has like bookmarked every time stamp of how i fucked up in sonic lore but i'm pretty sure in the video i was like i don't even know who i don't know who this person is but i know shadow like sonic fans are unfortunately like this glad so thank you for the super chat that comment instead honestly honestly you're right i should have actually pinned this comment you're so right i pray no this is not i'm this is not like satire or like an ironic this this guy took sonic very seriously um um hey guys thank you for the super chat thank you thank you this makes so little sense this has to be yeah next time next time if i if he comes back and i do
I'll make sure to pin the comment guys next time The pin of shame But yes Today is a very special day For Hollow Knight Silk Song No the Sonic fan Sonic is a very Toki Sonic is a very serious business How dare you make fun of I agree with his statement How dare you not know the Babylon Rouge trio I'm like quit off Wait actually let me google that I actually still don't know who they are.
I got shamed for it.
I still don't know.
Who the fuck are they?
Oh, it's like, who are these people?
I looked them up and I'm still like, who are they?
Are they from the comics?
Like, are they in any... Oh, they are a group that appears in the... What game have they appeared on?
Oh, only the racing ones.
Okay.
You know what?
No, that makes sense.
That makes sense.
They're literally only there in the racing games.
Because I was like, I was like, who are these people?
But no, they're only there for for all the racing games.
Yeah, literally only Sonic riding.
A simple-minded.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Joki, you're such a Sonic poser.
How dare you!
Big fan!
But anyway, today is a special day for Silk Song because we are gonna have our rematch with our very favorite enemy, the Savage Beastfly.
Um, I did farm, I did farm a little bit off stream for, uh, rosaries because, like, we're always broke in that game and I don't wanna, um, it was during a meeting too like meeting with my manager so like you know i made good use of my time just farming money while i was in that meeting um just going through all the stuff i have to do uh but we're not we're gonna be broke soon very soon the moment i spend all of this rosary because uh because this town is like i feel like i'm literally the only person with money in this town like that have spent something in 20 years and now they're trying to milk me as much as they can like literally there hasn't been any tourists in 20 plus years and that came in the town and then they suddenly jacked up all the prices they're like oh my god tourists is here and then they changed a five dollar water bottle to like 30 but like it's the only thing i can buy like it's like but it's the there's no other place for me to buy this water bottle i'm so thirsty
yeah yeah i'm like Oprah just moved into the neighborhood.
We got jacked up the prices now.
Can't have shit.
I'm the only one with money.
And they're trying to milk me as much as they can.
And I can't do anything to stop it.
I'm in a tourist trap.
Get me out.
I can't even leave the tourist trap.
trapped in a tourist trap.
I can't believe that's what it actually meant.
It's literal.
Okay, I'm gonna grab my cough drops real quick, guys.
Before we go, I'm kidding.
Guys, I don't know where I'm.
Oh, it's right next to me.
Okay.
Uh, all right.
It's actually right next to me.
I ordered it on Amazon.
Because, like, I didn't want to go out and get it yesterday.
So I just ordered it on, I just ordered, used my Amazon Prime and got it the next day.
I also ordered it in bulk, so I don't have to worry about buying more.
Alright, so, I'm, like, debating if I do it right up.
way or like warm up i feel like i should warm up a little bit like i i feel like logically i should warm up a little bit before okay so i'm here because i had to farm myself i don't know okay wait i feel like okay we can go to the flea right all right let's change we need a compass because i don't know where the fuck we are oh wait we have a compass never mind i'm down there Uh,
where does the flea live?
I don't remember.
Where does he live?
Yeah, I'm gonna have to warm up.
Because I have to buy, like, here, right?
He lives here.
Not flea.
Um, the, the, what are they?
What are they?
No, the, not the flea.
I don't even know what they are.
They're like ticks, right?
The ticks?
Because they have, like, really sharp needle noses.
The thieves, yeah.
The thieves.
They live here, right?
I don't remember where they live.
Because I need to buy stuff from them.
The Blastic Steps?
What the fuck is that?
I don't remember where they live.
Where the fuck is the Blastic Steps?
There's the slab.
Right next.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, there it is.
All right, we gotta go here.
All right, blast his steps.
Because I didn't spend my money before we do anything.
Return to the slab.
That's such a good comment.
Oh my god.
I think it makes me want to play more Sonic games.
And then just say like...
small little things that i know is like super wrong but i know that it will trigger them
it's a slave i was like i feel like i'm going too far yeah just small say like small little comments i know is like not correct not fully correct but i know would trigger them so hard just yeah just typical rage bait
even oh crafting kit yeah we'll grab that uh sand your what what are these oh spool fragment we'll need more spool yay more silk
what is this
is this good i don't even know what this is
oh it's a collectible what about these throw your big needle and scratch shiny straight Okay, I will grab this whenever I need a farm again
Beesmark, what's the fuck is the piece mark?
Oh, is it the one that I just bought?
Oh, okay.
Is there any other stores that I didn't spend money on yet?
I don't even know.
I feel like I bought everything I need.
Oh, wait, I gotta go back to...
I gotta donate to the wishboard.
All right, I lose rosaries when I get hit.
I just won't get hit.
That's so, like, I just won't get hit.
Did I have everything from Bellheart?
No, it wasn't to piss off a chatter.
Also, Lali, thank you for the super chatter.
Thank you, thank you.
It was to piss off another VTuber.
Pissing up chatter is a small shit.
next i i'm here for the next level rage bait
defender they give it a super chat thank you thank you there's an easy way to kill the beast flag too i don't want to ruin your fun experience against him thank you for this super chat thank you thank you multi-blind binary i'll grab i don't know if i should grab it for uh i have this for now.
I'll grab this.
Alright.
Oh, I should have enough for the wish...
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, we'll grab that later.
Alright, we'll grab this.
We'll grab the savage beast flight.
Here it is.
Here's the day.
And then...
I want to warm up a little bit before we go straight into the beast flight.
Give me a second.
I feel like... I don't... I feel like...
like it might be really fucking stupid to fight him right off the bat let me let me warm up just a little bit because all i did i was farming i don't think farming money was a good enough warm-up because i was literally just throwing my body onto until it died
all right okay if you guys really want really are hoping i first try this i definitely need a warm up.
Have you done it yet, Bellringer?
Wake wriggle deep, discover the depths of deception that brought this place so low?
If you speak of the citadel and the cell caretaker, then yes, I now know the start of it.
And the ward down below, I saw it clear, the hollow husk, and the many torturous implements, machines to instill a bug with thread that see their life extended.
Aye, that's it, in part, but there's more scale to it than all that.
Just think of greedily shoving the silk into the shells the madness that over kingdom eternal life for mortal bugs then think on how long it's all gone on also that's why they can use silk that's what the hospital was they were in they were doing silk implants and then they went crazy
the children born of them and all the pilgrims after the silk has seated deep into this kingdom shell No wonder Fireloom's bugs prove such easy prey for that haunted thread, and only to seek for itself to reach them.
Ho, ho, now you're seeing it, Bellringer.
Those poor pilgrims, all born bound to the cruel system of our world, now stricken in its new cursed web.
You at least are free from it and free to shake it all up if that's your choosing.
All right, lore time.
All right, let's donate a little.
bit to to this place we'll give we'll give the monks some money we'll donate to them to their little temple i have everything all
right all right we're about to go okay i know there was something down here yeah i have to grab this uh all right this is a good practice Oh!
I thought he was gonna jump.
I thought!
Oh, no!
Guys, this is exactly why I need a warm-up.
This is...
Now do you guys know why I have to warm up now?
Instantly, piety.
What's this?
Oh, secret.
Now you know, guys.
Wait, it's just silk.
There's nothing else.
Oh, it's a silk eater.
Oh, shit!
Okay, thank God I'm warming up.
Guys, this does not look like I can first try a beast fly right now.
I don't think I'm ready yet.
Get this way.
How do I play it?
Oh, hello?
She carries a precious cylinder.
She must give it, share it, claw to claw.
Pass it, and this wallkeeper shall grant their wisdom.
Just a small taste, a trickle, a glimmer of a citadel's sacred understanding.
What happened to him?
Why does he look like that?
Why does he have like a worm?
Did he have like a parasite?
Whoa!
Yes, yes, she gives.
It is ours.
I have passed a relic, Valkkeeper.
Now uphold your promise and aid me with your insight.
For demanding of a Valkkeeper, hers is impudence enough to bring death.
If she did not carry the scent of Weaver's spy.
So you know something of my ancestry, learned Bug.
If it gains me favor here, I'll expect your service in full...
Oh!
Does that mean like her parents used to live here or something?
They're dead dead your vicious kind they're meant to be better than we thinks to say as such But this one was taught it shall fold its claws it shall pass its knowledge as much as a glend Only a first child must of all keep or defer
Oh Amen.
Yeah, I know her dad's a god.
Don't worry, I've been using that everywhere I go.
I was like, um, do you know who you're talking to?
My father is a god.
But I'm saying like her mom's side.
Because her mom used to live here.
Because they're like my ancestors.
Yeah, I'm listening to a bug propaganda.
I'm thinking like for the for the Sonic if I do another Sonic stream and say things like um oh yeah did you guys know Knuckles is also a hedgehog
just little things I'll start with little things I'll start calling them coins even more and like I guys look my coins oh my god my coins the weaver spawn she has founded a positive sacred cylinder stolen from the dark below and then when i see tails i'll be like who's that guy who's that is that a new character oh he's a fox well i wonder why he has uh four tails
Never states our law.
Never must our melody pass to our bug.
Not Keeper, but you, fool, Weaver, will shatter those tenants with reckless age.
Your pontiff is gone, Vault Keeper.
The fellows have fallen to husk or thread.
What law once bound these vaults died with them.
Ha!
Fine, course she.
Claim the sacred song.
And paying to you if we are both are down forever for it.
Yay!
Let's play a song together.
And trusted, what did I do with it?
What can I do with your song?
music.
The soul of Varlum's eternal laid bare.
That, our cursed age, could still receive such blessing.
So, we respond.
Our melody is yours now.
Hell in mine, to carry beyond our walls.
Was the learning worth this feeling?
It was, well keeper.
I know to me your service continues.
Keep the cylinder safe along with my others, with any others I may bring.
What the fuck do I do with your son?
Can't even play it.
I can just play this.
Varlum!
reveal your secret all right never mind i'm too i don't want to listen to your son no more but it's like what do i do with it
oh it was for the main quest oh i was like what the do i do with the son give me your money it's time it's time for me to take your lunch money pay up buddy all right let's grab um let's grab the other cylinder first and then how do i get up there again oh it's over here i forgot to kill this guy let's grab the other cylinder first and then and then we'll do savage peace flag oh could it be is that the silk song
Okay, where is it?
Holy fuck, it's so far.
But, like, it won't be easier.
If I just go straight, I feel like it'd be easier.
I'll just get the main one up top.
And then, we'll do the savage beast.
Look, I have to warm up!
Banu.
Okay, that's the card core.
Okay.
All right, we go up.
You have rare chosen to have ascended this final threshold.
Listen to our wish, deliver it that you may rise above and see your pilgrimage end.
We will hear the song of the architects at the core of our citadel.
They used to sustain our realm, its walls, its floors, and its floors, even though sludders fall silent.
We'll hear the voice of keepers within their grand vaults.
They who guard a history are prayers and our secrets across the ages.
We'll hear the melody of the conductors high in their glimmering towers.
They bear in the heaviest mantle who are glad.
Oh wait, I can't access this.
We're jealous of our threefold song.
Oh yeah, this was the mission.
Whoops.
Oh, sorry.
Alright.
I just never talked to them, so I never knew.
That's crazy.
I've never talked to these people, so I didn't know I was supposed to do that until I until I until now stairs up or down to the right?
Like here?
Yeah, I'm like, how the fuck do I get there?
Here?
Oh.
I'm not gonna grab the one at the top.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, this is open.
open.
Oh.
What?
Oh, now I can go up.
Wee.
Wait, shortcuts downstairs?
Oh, got the shirt.
Oh, I should grab the chair.
You're right.
Just in case.
All right.
Apaco.
Thank you for the elevator.
Oh, this looks very parkour-ish.
Yep.
I fucking knew it.
I was like, this has to be parkour-related.
Yeah.
That's fine.
Oh, I thought I could out-perry that.
I thought I could be a gamer.
Wait, can I do this as a shortcut?
Oh, I'm not- I don't have- I have the hunter's crest.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Oh, nice.
I forgot I have the hunter's crest for this.
Yeah, I'm- what?
I go- what?
I'm a little confused.
Oh, there's a wall.
Oh, shit.
I didn't notice the wall.
All right, wait.
Give me a sec.
We're going to restart this.
I'm changing crest.
I don't care.
I don't want to make this harder for myself.
This feels like a Pogo map.
Like, I have.
I feel like I have to.
Yeah, I'm going to change crest.
This shit looks way too fucking tilting.
Way too tilting to do normally.
Oh wait, no, I shouldn't do that.
Uh...
Wait, I don't need it yet, actually.
We'll grab poison for now.
Wait, actually...
Do the binds.
Wait, what the fuck is this?
Oh, the silk.
No, it's fine.
I don't think...
Oh, actually...
We're going...
Actually, maybe.
So we can just grab more HP.
No, damage is better.
I think getting more silk if I get hit is better.
I think.
I feel like...
I feel like if I get damaged a lot...
Oh, if I get damaged a lot...
Then at least I can have...
I can regen myself for heals.
Hello.
Which is...
Oh shit.
Okay, I was...
That was just greedy.
That's greedy.
Um, um, actually.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That was just pure greed.
Oh, I should have got the claws thing to make parkour easier.
It's literally right there too.
It's over here.
Why did it make me go there?
Oh my god, I forgot about these guys.
There you go.
Friend!
Wait, why do I like green?
Oh, it's from the...
It's from the damage that I took.
Ah!
Alright, too soon.
Became bug chowder.
Okay.
That scared me a little, but I'm okay.
Where do I go?
Oh?
No!
Oh, please tell me that's down.
Oh, okay.
It is down.
5-3.
Do it again!
Oh!
No!
I slowly float down.
This area fucking sucks.
Okay.
Oh god damn it forgot that there was a gear there I hate this area
I'm not I'm not warmed up to pogo
Guys I'm not warmed up enough to parkour
God I hope this doesn't mess me up though later
Oh, no.
No!
Oh, I don't feel so good.
Oh, my god.
I hate you.
Are you serious?
Are you fucking...
Oh, this is over.
It's so over for me.
Oh, we made it.
It's not over.
over oh i can't see
okay we'll ignore him ignore him what is this oh i just have to align oh i just have to align this is that alignable
Okay.
Oh, why is choice?
Yeah, I was like, nope.
How about no?
Are none of these alignable?
Oh, here it is.
Okay.
And then this.
There we go.
Oh, that's easy.
That's an easy.
Oh, they already did like half of this for me.
Not too bad.
This is a puzzle for babies!
Okay, none of these line up.
Is it?
Yeah, none of these line...
But this lines up.
Oh, wait, it doesn't.
Does it?
No, this doesn't.
Yeah.
Okay, now it lines up.
Okay, nice.
He's gotta do this then.
Huh?
lines up what do you mean oh oh never mind there you go it was just like one thing that i couldn't see all right uh
okay oh wait that's a they already did like three two of it for me that's nice of them There you go.
Last one.
Easiest puzzle in my life.
Maybe it's this...
Nope.
Thing is, I don't know if they're repeating.
Oh wait, oh wait, no, never mind.
I said, I didn't!
Uh, nope.
Nope.
God damn it.
How about this one?
It's just, actually, it's just trial and error.
I'm the worst part is at the jump so far for this one.
Why did they put the lever on the right side?
And then built platforms?
Are they stupid?
Is the architect stupid?
Who paid for this architect?
If the handle is on the right, maybe put the platforms on the...
right side there is a wall what do you think every bug can walk that
not every bug can walk them
oh that's pretty This is where all the pilgrims taxpaying payers money went to.
One part of the three-fold memory.
Well, maybe I could just get the three memories right off the bat.
This is where it went to.
To build large ass...
To build these large ass MP3 players.
Oh my god.
What happened to that bug?
Wait, what?
I just go straight down?
Oh my god, I have to climb all the way down.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I touched that.
fucking wall I was like yay I'm doing it I joked so many things I don't even know where my silk is where did it go no I did it again oh my god it's down there somewhere
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
It's fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
Um...
I think I just have to go this way.
This might be easier to go down with.
Oh, so that's why they built these guys.
Alright, there you go.
Smooth sailing.
Oh.
That should be fine.
All right, let's sit on that chair so we don't get respawned back to the top.
Nice.
All right, now we'll get this other part.
They have to be all parkour, right?
Unless there's a boss fight for the third one.
Because I remember you guys were saying that the third one was also the hardest to get.
Oh, God, they're so tall.
wait i hear him how do i get him i hear him snoozing is he up here is there a secret up here
all right the third one will be my warm-up i hear the i hear him i hear the little dog he went where is how do we get up there hello down here oh okay i don't know how to get down there.
Oh, well, I guess he'll starve.
I guess.
Oh, I forgot to change my crest.
Oh, wait.
There's a bench over there.
Are you serious?
He jumps?
That's it.
I ain't playing.
Oh, my God.
He's stealing myself.
Get out of here!
Fucking thief!
Oh, my God!
Okay, I didn't think he'd do that.
He stole my silk and killed and then used it against me.
What a whore.
Oh, I forgot.
Yeah, this is my...
Yeah, this is exactly why I need a warm-up.
Okay, where's my silk?
God, I need this warm-up.
This way.
Where's the chair?
Oh, there it is.
How the fuck?
How do I get there?
Oh, I missed it.
Okay, it's...
Alright, let's grab...
Let's change the crest.
Wait, is it parkour?
Guys.
Is it parkour?
Or is it...
Boss fight?
Kinda?
Yes?
Okay.
Do we need Pogo?
That is, like, the most important question.
Or I'll just use this crest.
Both?
Okay.
Apako.
Now use this, then.
Because I only use the wonder if I have to fight something.
Oh.
That's weird that it gave me a full bar of silk.
That's so weird.
Alright, before I unused the bathroom, actually.
Okay.
It's a little weird.
So I gotta have a pee break in case I get an angry pee out.
All right, I'm back, everybody.
Yeah, thank you.
Let's super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, thank you.
Let's super chat.
Thank you.
Remember to drink water, fellow dragons.
Don't worry about me.
I got beer.
I'm hydrating as well.
Thank you, let's super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
I'm still thinking about that comment.
There's so many layers to it.
Okay, I was just thinking while I was angry peeing because that's where like you know like shower thoughts these are pee thoughts
you know how they're like they're like how they named the Avengers as the greatest crossover in history and I'm like bro I can name so many things that have a better crossover than the Avengers because the Avengers they all came from Marvel that's barely that's like they all came from Marvel.
That's barely a fucking crossover.
They are all owned under the same company.
Kingdom Hearts is a better crossover than fucking Avengers.
It's barely a crossover when they're all owned by the same fucking company.
Literally.
You could have named so many other games but you named the Avengers
What about Fortnite?
Oh, that's a lot of dead bodies.
Alright.
Sucks for those bugs that can't swim.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Wait, I don't like these guys.
Oh, my god.
Okay, now I know.
Wait, he can keep calling?
them?
No, my buddy!
Oh, it's okay.
I can get it.
There you go.
Okay.
Now I know what you guys meant.
It's not fair.
He has, like, little minions.
That ain't fair.
How dare you?
How dare you, bright-up minions?
If I could bring up my dragons, I would in a heartbeat.
Oh?
Oh.
Oh, that's a parry.
Okay.
Okay, they can parry, too.
If I could just chuck my dragoons at people, I would.
Okay, maybe I do need...
No, I don't need Pogo.
There you go.
Okay, that's right.
Your master's dead!
Wee!
Wait, why do I need Oh shit.
Wait, I don't like this.
Oh my god.
Okay, I really don't like this.
I don't like how the water...
Okay, now I definitely don't like how the water pushes me back.
Oh, I should have brought the magnet too.
Alright, up I go.
You'd be like my little Pokemans.
I'd be like, go, dragon, go!
What's this?
Oh, that was just for money?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Does that mean it's down?
Oh, that means it's down.
Down is up.
Okay, I was gonna say, where do I go?
Okay.
Unlock.
Hello.
I'm here to rob you.
Nimi, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
We had a great stream, Nimi.
I don't know what you were playing, but I hope you had a good time.
Hello.
Today is the day where I fight the savage beast fly.
I have no map.
I'm lost.
Lottie, think of the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You're like the one trainer with five matches.
Magikarp.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Dracles, come on.
Have higher expectations of yourself.
You're like my metapod.
Because at least a Magikarp, they can splash and move.
All you can do is harden.
It's shell plates and cogs.
That could be fashioned into flying.
Okay.
Yeah, sure.
Oh, I can't.
I don't like...
How do I make it?
Oh, wow.
Too real.
See, you don't move and all you know is hard.
Oh, I need ore.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Oh, I'm...
This way too close for comfort right now.
I know this is the right way to go.
Oh, it has to be.
There's a lover here.
She knows us too well.
Thank you, Super Chat Allen.
Thank you, thank you.
Wish I have a map here.
We're secure when I need her.
Okay, Rosary.
Yay!
Oh, wait.
Am I robbing a baby?
That's right.
What's a baby gonna do with money anyway?
I'll miss the secret room.
Well, too late.
It's not that bad.
This looks...
Scary.
This place ain't that bad.
I just don't know where to go.
Because there's so many places to go.
Oh, there's a bench.
Oh, there's an elevator.
Nice.
Down, that's it.
Thank God I have money.
In this economy right now.
What's this?
Oh, oh, thank God.
Okay.
Map 2.
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the I'll give the shows, thank you, thank you.
Papa, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I was a dokey mod once.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, is this, oh, it's an arena.
Oh, it's an arena.
No, not the arena.
Okay.
Okay, I gotta focus up for this.
Bravo!
Oh my god, and they can use poison?
Oh wait, it's my poison.
I accidentally used my poison.
Wait, I forgot I have tools.
That's right!
Oh shit.
I have tools!
Okay, I want to get rid of these guys.
I hate them so much.
I forgot.
I have had...
Oh shit!
Not him!
I'm sure about him!
I heard lots of things about you!
Oh!
Okay, that's fine.
So, it's the hammer.
mad okay that was an accident but that's fine
twin i mean you know poison is not too bad oh my god it's fine i can heal from him i can heal from him i can heal there's too many people
Are you serious?
A fucking bell?
That's it.
Give me your lunch money.
I have tools!
I keep forgetting, but I do have them.
Stupid bodyguide.
Oh no.
No!
I don't know!
Oh,
shit!
I don't know where to look at!
There's so many things to look at!
Okay, I'm gonna...
I keep accidentally using this.
Alright, uh, I need to...
Oh, I need to go back to the bench.
I was doing so good too.
It's a big voice.
They take up, like, 80% of the screen!
I almost had it.
I almost had it, too.
There was just too many big voice.
Okay, this is actually a good warm-up, though.
Oh, I thought I could.
I don't know.
There you go.
I'm a little bit brute-forcing this right now.
Alright, that's fine.
Go!
Oh, did not mean to accidentally ran into him?
Nice.
Boomerang!
Boomerang can't fail me!
Oh my god, this stupid, stupid silk eater.
Okay, I want to get rid of him first.
Oh, he's not dead?
Okay, now he is.
Okay, nice.
Okay, big boy time.
Chainsaw!
Oh shit!
Get him away from me!
Oh my god, I almost forgot about.
There you go.
Okay, I did almost use the majority of my tools, so I don't know about the next part.
I might have made an oopsie and used the majority of everything.
Twin!
Okay, fine.
Okay, I'm gonna go use this for him.
Because I won't get him out of here fast.
Okay, I think it's...
Oh, it's not big boy time.
Yeah, that's good.
That's good.
Oh,
that was an accident.
I did not mean to use chainsaw.
I wanted to kill him.
Okay, this is where things get a little scary.
Chainsaw.
Just chainsaw.
Oh, I actually ran into him, but that's okay.
Oh.
oh my god oh my god get me out of here
okay okay oh okay i'm so scared yes second try oh my god okay i'm I used all the tools I had there.
Okay.
That was a good warm-up.
Okay, second try.
We did it.
I used everything I had.
All my util for this run.
A visitor.
Now this is rare.
Savage Beastfly won't stand a chance with this warm-up now.
This is it.
Warm up over.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for savage bees fly.
I must apologize for not rising to greet you.
After an age spent stickily, I found myself unable to lift from this bedchamber.
Is this your silk?
At least you're still able to poop out silk, though, right?
I hope.
Good pilgrim.
Oh, unless this is like for him to live forever type deal.
Oh, I hope you're a good pilgrim.
Arceladus shown you the courtesy.
Deserved, I would both devout.
To me again.
I've borne its hospitality.
Hospitality.
Well enough, aged one.
My sympathies, pilgrim.
We have fallen so far.
And now, sadly, we become seeking aid or understanding.
I fear I too shall disappoint.
Oh, so it's like a silk transfusion.
Yeah.
It's like, yeah, I was going to say, is it like an IV bag?
It's getting a silk transfusion.
He's just 90% silk now, holding it together.
And now, Sally, if I'm seeking aid or understanding, I fear I too shall disappoint.
Where you would ask, I have only my melody left to offer.
It is a simple thing, as small as of gifts.
But it's more special now, for it's been rarely heard in these quieted times.
Wait, is that the song where you just moaning in pain?
He's just like, I'm having a heart attack.
Oh.
I don't think that's what he's singing, but okay.
No.
He is trying, don't you.
Our song upon a silken thread.
Such beautiful sound.
So long, absent from our halls.
For memory, Melody, good pilgrim, shall likely be the last to receive it.
I mean, he is running out of silk.
I mean, I could give him my silk, but, like, I think I might need it more.
Sorry, I'm sorry.
I'm fighting the savage beast for that.
Oh, is he choking?
I could save his life because I do have unlimited silk, but I need to save the world right now, okay?
I can't be saving everybody.
in this place yeah what oh wait you're right but what's his silk type though you're right guys we don't know what his silk type is okay we're gonna be fighting savage beast fly we're gonna have other weapons okay okay
uh don't put that here and this is a good loadout
oh fuck okay it's time it's fucking time oh my god i'm so nervous
i have to first try it too which is the extra stressful part all right i'm gonna full focus okay i assume i got it's is it close to Bellheart.
I'm gonna full focus.
Where is it?
It is.
Track down the Savage Beastfly in Farfields.
Okay, where's Farfields?
Oops.
Oh, lost my silk.
Oh, okay.
My heart's beating so fast right now.
Where the fuck is Farfields?
God, this map is so big.
Apparently, I was reading about it, and they cut out so many things in Silk Song.
Like, the map, they showed, like, a concept art of what the map should be.
Like, what the original map was like.
So, and they cut out, like, I think, like, 30% of the map.
Of the original map, which is crazy, because already it feels like a lot.
Okay, here.
Alright.
Oh!
He's fly too is where I fought the mech.
Okay, I'll sit in the chair.
I- here?
That's his head, right?
So it should be here.
Alright.
It's down here.
I'm gonna farm silk off real quick.
I'm gonna farm silk off this one guy.
He's my silk farmer.
Because I know you respawn.
That's like, this is your purpose.
To be my farm.
Oh.
Oh, fuck.
My heart is beating so fast.
I've never...
Oh, my God.
I've never been so nervous.
We're full of silk.
Cool.
Calm down.
Oh.
I got hit myself up.
pipe myself up you can do this you could do this dokey all right oh i i can feel it i know it i remember what it looks like oh my god all right where is he oh my god he's literally coming back from hell just to kill me i'm focusing okay that was not what i wanted to do but that's okay
are you kidding me okay that's fine
oh my god why is the platform on
oh no damage to my
god no damage run that's right while you were lying in hell i was i was grinding leveling up while you laid there in hell coasting, thinking I was the little bug you first fought
the power creeps is great I was studying the nail while you sit down there in hell that's right
that's a key You're right.
I mastered the use of toys.
Warma was actually helpful.
No way.
Baby, thank you.
That's it for chat.
Thank you.
Easy.
Oh my god.
You should have stayed in hell.
You should have fucking stayed in hell.
Time to eat the shoe.
Let's go.
Yay!
It's shoe time.
Melania, I believe this is yours.
What a gamer.
Cyber Dragon.
Thank you for the Akka Super.
Thank you.
I hope she chooses a very expensive shoe.
Not only... I should get a boat... For those who don't know, I did see the clip that Temma will eat a shoe if I first try the Savage Beast Fly.
So that's why I was so nervous and scared because I was like, oh my, that's so much fresh air.
I deserve a bonus.
I not only first try the Savage Beast Fly, but I did it with zero hits.
Zero, that's like a bonus.
I should be able to choose the shoe at that point.
No, I deserve to choose what kind of shoe she has to eat.
No damage.
First try.
All right.
Now back to the...
Now that I finished the main game, let's go do the side quest now.
Behold, the power of Duchess.
Don't keep it.
Ever since I became a Duchess, I just leveled up.
My skills just improved.
Who would have thought?
Royalty does make me a better person.
Oh, I'm George.
Thank you.
Eat two shoes.
Oh, my gosh.
My heart was beating so fast.
I got the Royalty.
royal buff oh my god my heart is actually was actually beating so fucking much guys i was like so nervous i don't want to go oh yeah i'd go this way
no that that third area was actually it's such good worry about
because like it made me remember how to use tools because i forgot how to use tools earlier like, wait, I have, I have a boom, oh my god, okay.
I just realized I forgot to redo my, god damn it, stupid silk spiders.
I forgot to redo my, uh, my inventory.
Oh, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I used all my stuff perfectly there.
Oh, thank god I did that.
I think I did the third stage, the third arena.
It, like, made me be All right, poison.
I feel like I need more tools in general.
Oh, wait.
I gotta get the chainsaw back.
I'm glad I still remember how to fight that fucker too.
I was like, it's been 20 years since I saw that saw you.
I, like, my fucking muscle memory kicked back in after I bashed my head against the wall against him.
All right, don't worry.
I have it.
I didn't go in the high halls to make the spiders.
Okay, I got...
Let me eliminate the spiders real quick.
I shall be the only spiders left in this world.
I didn't...
The scary part was that I actually got an iframe earlier.
With my pogo.
I think I saw it.
I should have been hit in one area, but I did an iframe pogo.
Oh,
wait.
I just realized.
There's statues of the people I got the song from.
Pilgrim, who would hold our strong within your shell?
Rise above.
Offer your most devout self onto our secret heart.
Okay, before I do, I gotta eliminate the spiders.
I acknowledge you, my gamer chief.
Please teach me how to be like you.
DJ, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
Sometimes you're just born of it.
Born with it, bro.
I'm sorry.
You just, sometimes you're just born with it, you know?
You see it.
I became the Duchess of Sudan and was became royalty it everything changed for me or just become yeah we just become royalty crazy thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um I'm trying to fucking speedrun this game and this goofy avi youtuber one tries the savage beast fly while I'm having to retry sister splinter for the eighth of fucking time gg thank you Thank you,
thank you.
Oh yeah, almost forgot to mention.
Thank you, thank you, Silent.
But I will be doing a sponsor stream for Etheria Restarts Global Fest on the 28th of September at 5 p.m.
PST.
Almost forgot to announce that.
But on Sunday, we have an extra stream and it will be a sponsor stream.
It will be my usual time slot at 5 p.m.
PST.
I'll make a waiting room for that on Saturday too on on Sunday sorry on Sunday for that stream and thank you for the reminder sorry I got so um I got so zoned in focusned on with the savage beast that I almost forgot but thanks for the reminder yeah so there be a Sunday stream so where do I go for is it Is it here?
Is it here?
Where do I go?
To kill the spider people?
Oh, go to where?
Oh, here.
That's where I robbed the baby.
Oh my god, I have to do the parkour thing all over again.
Okay.
That's fine.
I have to do the parkour thing.
Oh, I opened the short.
Oh, I don't?
Really?
Wait, where is this place?
Try to remember how to get there first.
Oh, I can go up from the bench area?
Oh, I didn't know that.
Alright, we'll do that.
Next, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thing.
Yeah, that too.
I gotta pay off the...
For spending 2k at one time, 1k on being royalty.
Okay, here it is.
Oh.
Here?
Where is it?
I pushed this?
I know, I'm pushing a dead baby.
Wait, no, it's not.
Oh, here?
Oh, it's here.
I was like, I thought I was like waiting for...
Wait, what?
I'm jumping!
Why can't I reach it?
Zechra, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, there it is.
Poor grace.
I was like wondering, why can't I fucking...
Oh my gosh, this is another boss fight.
Oh, look, it's another baby.
Are you kidding me?
Oh my god, Chris.
Oh my god, okay.
How do I struggle with this?
But...
But like, first tribe, savage beast fly.
I don't understand.
Oh my...
I hate them so much.
They're so annoying.
They're actually so annoying.
Oh my god.
Okay, I got heals in time.
Wait, just run?
Oh, they spawn forever?
Oh, my God.
I can't...
There's no way.
There's no way they infinite spawn.
Oh, my God.
First try Savage Beastfly.
But these spotters are the...
These spotters...
I didn't know!
Get me out of here!
No!
Harder than Beast Flag confirmed.
Oh my god, I did it.
Oh, I forgot to sit in a chair.
I forgot.
Wait, what?
Is this yet?
He's harder than Savage Beast Flag confirmed.
They just don't stop.
Oh, is it?
Oh, here.
Oh, okay.
I lost it all.
There's a cooldown, okay guys?
I used up all my...
I used up all my cooldowns on Savage Beast Flat.
Let's sit down on this chair.
Even I can't beat Infinity, exactly.
There you go.
Alright.
Pushing my dead baby.
as a platform.
There we go.
Okay, I think it was here.
Oh, God.
Ah.
Okay.
Alright.
It's okay.
They can't get up here.
Oh, and then there's more.
Alright, let's see.
Is that it?
Did it disappear now?
Are you gone?
Are you all dead?
Oh, they're all dead now?
Yay!
That's fucking right.
Get out of here, spiders!
No more stealing my silk.
Alright, nice.
They're now extinct.
I shall be the only spider left in this world.
Alright.
Now that we've fixed that.
I guess we can go up now.
Wait, what?
How do we get there?
Okay, instructions are a little unclear.
Uh...
How the fuck do we get up there?
The elevator?
Oh, the other elevator!
Oh my god, I forgot about that guy.
Okay, I was just like, Elevator?
What elevator?
Yeah, where I fought the cage, yeah, in the dancing room.
Alright, we'll go here then.
I forgot that.
I forgot the main quest.
Look, The Savage Beast Fly Like was Took up all my memory space So I like instantly deleted Whatever the fuck I did before
The moment I killed the savage Beast Fly Nothing else matters in life
Hey Jokey that one guy Short Hollow Knight Edition seems to be doing Numbers gotta say it was my intention For you to never upgrade your nail you goober I did say kinda
It's not my fault you got one guy.
Oh, that's beautiful.
Oh, it's lace.
Hello there.
I heard she gets like a lot faster.
I forgot how to fight her.
She wasn't that memorable to me because it took me like two tries.
I think.
Sorry, the Jimmy don't... Oh, I should have got... I should have got parry.
I mean, it's not too late.
Oh my god, I ran into that!
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, yeah, never mind.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I don't know why I was, like, looking at my map.
Okay, guys, I don't think I'm first trying her.
Oh my god, didn't dodge that?
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
She's a...
Her pattern is different.
Oh, her pattern is a lot different.
Where am I?
Okay.
Alright, I understand her patterns, though.
I don't remember how she played.
And I was like, wait, I don't...
This is so different.
Alright, we'll get Perry.
I've rather changed for Perry.
Alright, I understand, though.
Don't worry, I've downloaded her.
Yeah, she's also a lot faster.
Fun.
God damn it.
I'm using all my dice.
Now I like these tools.
I think these tools are fine, right?
Uh, yeah, these two are fine.
Alright.
I have to be, like, less...
I can be aggressive, but I also have to be, like, super patient.
She wasn't that memorable to me, because it took me two tries to kill her last time.
So, like, I don't remember how to fight.
Beastflight!
I bashed my head for two hours, like, for, like, an hour straight.
a bike fighting him again.
Oh, I wanted to parry first.
There you go.
Her parry is so... Her parry is so annoying.
Okay.
Wrong way.
What?
Ah, I forgot to say that!
Wait, did I say that?
I said that in a bench.
I jumped in her.
Oh, okay, she's...
I have to focus.
Oh, I legitimately, if I lose focus, it's over.
I lose the rhythm.
Do you remember now?
I lose focus when I start yapping.
Because she has, like, a rhythm to her.
I also want to use the parry more, too.
Jesus!
That's my parry!
Okay.
What?!
Okay, I thought I was gonna get the parry.
That's why I was super aggressive for it.
Jesus, her range is quick.
Her range is crazy!
Okay, I'm focused.
I'm focused.
I'm gonna focus up now.
Her range is crazy.
She's not the same as her first iteration.
Yeah, she has a parry mix-up.
all right i'm focused i'm focused no yab no yab i'm gonna kill her this is my this is my my gary and pokemon oh okay now i focus
i haven't used yeah
Oh, she's so fast now.
Oops, wrong way.
Are you serious?
Okay, my turn.
No, I didn't have enough!
I was trying to parry!
But I didn't realize I didn't have my parry anymore.
Oh, me too.
I wanted the parry not fair
are you serious oh my god she got me with the parry oh my god her mom it's my turn to parry oh she got me with her parry i haven't parried in so long i don't even know it's because i haven't parried in so long i don't remember how to do it Cool.
All right, here you go.
I'm just gonna use, I'm gonna use like...
Here we go.
Oh!
I actually didn't mean to...
God damn it!
Okay.
Are you serious?
That's fine.
I'll use my tools.
Where did she come from?
Oh my god.
Sometimes I'm like, where does she come from?
Are you sick?
Ah, she teleports!
She's reading me better than me!
Oh my god, she's input reading.
She's input reading.
Oh, fuck this.
I can't parry right now.
She's too fast.
I'm not using parry.
She's way too fast.
She anti-aired me.
Nothing personal.
Okay.
No, yeah.
For real.
I hate her.
Okay, I accidentally ran into her.
God damn it!
I keep thinking she's gonna do...
I...
Oh!
I hate...
I hate this attack.
Oh, what?
I did not jump there!
Okay, that's fine.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's okay.
I'm gonna be more patient.
Okay.
Okay,
that's good.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, I did an accident!
I was trying to use my tools.
I didn't mean to use a thread storm.
I didn't mean to use my thread.
Oh, my God.
Sometimes it, like, doesn't read my...
Doesn't read my directional input.
Oh.
You still...
on this fight.
Okay.
I miss Baby Lace.
Oh my god.
God damn it!
Because I don't know where she'll TP.
Yeah.
Get out of here.
Are you serious?
You're such a whore.
You're actually such a whore.
Okay.
I thought I dodged it too.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
No!
Ah!
She baits me so hard!
She actually She's like she could read my mind.
She could actually read my mind She knows like she's thinking ten steps ahead.
I'm like doing it I'm like I'm like enjoying one step at a time and she's like ten steps ahead of me She knows my next life.
She knows what I'm gonna eat tomorrow.
She knows my two-year plan
I don't even know my two-year plan
What the
Okay.
He's so paranoid.
What?
Are you serious?
I land on her.
Okay, I thought she was gonna dodge.
I keep thinking she's gonna par-
I'm so paranoid about the
parry.
Are you...
Fuck you!
That's right, you missed bitch!
Okay, I got two.
Woo!
What happened?
Holy shit, she's so much faster.
Are you serious?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I got to the third phase though.
I got to the third phase.
I had to like figure out her new pattern.
the landing I have no more tools never surrender okay get chuggled what I jump oh my god this is my worst ride it's actually my worst ride I mean if I ever think what
happened I just I don't know happen I my brain just DC'd but someone unplugged my routing so they plugged the router from my head into my brain I'm throwing I'm actually throwing now I regress she's in my head
okay focus focus I need a jump for that
Eh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
I've downloaded you, bitch!
Oh shit!
No, I deserve that.
I absolutely deserve that.
Here we go.
I figured you out.
Every time!
No, I deserve that.
Jesus Christ.
Oh!
I mean, I'll take that.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Okay.
How she's still there?
Oh no.
This is bad.
This is so bad.
This is...
She did the double dash.
She double dashed it.
The moment I'm like, I figured you out.
She's like, did you really?
Did you really figure me out?
The double dash.
She's like, oh, you thought you figured me out, did you?
I did.
I thought I did.
Yeah, I don't have tools anymore.
But, oh my.
Okay, I need to remember when she does the jump there.
I'm regressing again.
Okay, this is...
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
I had to jump.
I forgot about jumping.
Can you fire him silk off of you?
Bitch.
This is why your mom doesn't love you.
You're an orphan.
Yeah, where's your mom?
My mom is at least sleeping or dead.
I don't know which if this is a sequel or a prequel
At least I know I have a mom
Oh shit.
Okay, that was an accident
Okay Fuck, I didn't know she does that!
I thought I was being so clever.
I was like, oh, she's gonna do a double dash.
Let me just, let me just, like, float a little bit.
And then she fucking jumps down and slam dunks me to the floor.
She fucking slam dunks me on the floor while I was just, I was like, yay, let me float.
Both have mommy issues.
Don't care.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
What?
I reacted very poorly there.
Oh my god, you were ready to jump.
Oh my god, this is my worst run!
See everything!
He's protecting everything!
This was...
Now that's my worst run.
Oh.
She read me, she read me like a book.
She now knows, like, she knows how I'm gonna die and everything.
She knows, she knows my retirement plan.
She knows when and how I'm gonna die.
She knows everything.
She downloaded me.
Like, my book was like an instruction guide.
God damn it, I need to remember it.
Oh, what?
No!
Okay.
God damn it!
I need to remember that's the jump button.
Like, that's when she jumps up, like right here.
I swear to God, I looked the others way, but like for some reason,
I was...
Okay.
Danny remember.
Yeah.
Jesus, that's the jump.
That's the jump.
Stupid double dash!
Fuck this.
I know this is not the run, but I'm doing that just because I can.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god, this is stupid slash.
Friend?
Fuck, oh my god, fuck me too.
Oh
fuck, I'm too fast.
Oh my god, I was too fast.
Oh, did I do it?
Be in a dream!
That's why I'll push you off the edge.
Get off.
Get off the edge.
Oh.
Congratulations, Spider.
I felt your sting.
And you bear the truth of my pathetic empty shell.
No.
I've always had the scent, child.
You are an old bug.
Yours is a life born entirely from Thread.
Wait, you're from Thread?
You're just silk?
Life.
You're too dangerous.
This week, wasting existence.
This was not life, just a tusk shaped to act as a child.
Yours was life, Peta 1.
No confuse your unique creation with its absence.
I've seen others make the same mistake.
Palatitude, Spider, from you.
Don't be gross.
Head on, climb up in a way.
You've earned your audience with the divine.
This is not the run.
Don't keep logic.
Let's thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Face the holy mother who had fashioned so cruel and crude a daughter as me.
After all, it's you that she wants this.
Oh, she does have mommy issues.
Hey, we can be good friends.
We both have mommy issues.
At least my mom wants me.
You and I are not the same.
My mom just went on an eternal slumber, but she wants me.
After all, it's you that she wants, is it not?
Oh my gosh.
And even, I, both mom wants me.
Don't keep, please.
Aw.
Look at that.
Wow, Hornet, how come you get three moms?
A door.
Oh, press what?
It's too late.
Too late.
I'm here for the moms.
What the fuck is this?
One to wish are waiting.
Better a child's fun.
Mad than... than none.
From our silk, a child, we're loyal.
How many tries did it take to beat Lace?
It's just, I- her parries just threw me off.
I felt like she was- she- I felt like this boss definitely does input reading.
Because like, she knew exactly what- like, like she read my mind.
She know- she knew when and where I was gonna die.
Or, like, she knew, like, how it's gonna dodge.
Alright, let's play here.
Oh.
Hello?
Hey.
Come on.
Wake up.
Hey.
You...
Is she...
Hello?
How can she die?
She's just silk.
what's your silk type I'm silk oh so it's I'm a universal silk donor don't worry let her sleep don't worry girl I'm a universal silk donor I could save you
no keep losing Alex thank you in the super chat thank you thank you ladies changes their attacks mid mood to try and react to how you dodge is not in your head thank you for the super chat thank you thank you to silk pr all right how do i okay i have to go up how do i get go even higher
yeah i'm oh it's this one i was gonna be like how do i go up this is how oh wait there's a secret here All right.
Changes the time.
Mid-moot to try and react.
Okay, so he does input.
I fucking knew it.
I was like, why does it feel like she knows what I'm doing?
Fucking knew it.
Bench to the right.
Oh, here?
Wait.
Where the fuck is that?
Bench?
What's the door?
Oh, down below.
Wait, what's over here?
God, I don't know.
Oh, the lever I activated.
Oh!
I thought I activated something.
The one above me.
Oh, I didn't realize this was a door.
Oh, shit!
Where am I?
It fell down another hole.
Wait, where is this?
Oh, it's the terminal!
It's the elevator room.
I found it.
Yeah.
Okay.
But at least I only felt different from the other bosses I fought.
Just felt like...
Okay.
Like, I felt like I had to, like, I had, she was reading me and I had to read her.
Weaver in eighth part, last of the line.
Rail with age, tracked and taken in Sansteen waste.
Seven cursors, nine envos lost attack.
Like, we were just reading each other.
I was like playing, I felt like I was playing chess with her.
Weaver in quarter part, last of the line.
tracked and taken beneath the city of seal.
Eight core stairs, 12 envoys lost to task.
Quick dokey, the saver, use your needle to inject your... Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Lolly.
I assume I just go up.
It's like a heartbeat.
That was the widow's cage.
Oh.
Oh, wait, are we at the final boss?
Is there anything here?
Oh, what's here?
Secret.
That's what's here.
Oh, it's just silk.
Okay, that's cool.
Alright.
Not as cool of a secret.
Is it really just silk?
Oh, playing me.
Music?
Here?
Wake,
wake, wake.
Oh, is this the widow?
Glory to you of the first and the last.
Devotion to you.
We hear you.
Spin, bind, punish.
Our light, divine.
Our mother, true.
Wake, wake, wake.
Okay, that's the same.
She's seeing the same thing.
Oh, it's the widow.
Too bad she's dead.
That is open.
Whoa!
Oh, is this shortcut?
Oh, it's a shortcut.
Yeah.
I killed her.
And her stupid bells.
Oh my god.
They're going to go straight into it.
Oh, wait.
This is literally the...
just do this part yeah i just did this parkour in my dreams
this is literally the same parkour i was doing in my dreams wait sit sit where there's no chair here i already sat on the far right
oh all right all right let's see let's kill this big ball of self Okay.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
Wait, she's hot.
Grandmother silk.
Wait, your mom's hot.
Oh shit!
What the fuck was that?
I got so confused.
Oh my god, I'm so scared.
I'm so scared.
I'm just gonna heal just in case.
Oh.
Oh!
Rocks!
Not the rocks!
Please don't tell me she can send rocks out!
Wow!
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Oh, God.
She's gonna start sending rocks out, isn't she?
Oh my god, fuck!
Hello?
Oh no, not the spikes.
I like how she didn't move.
She's like, hey, when are you gonna...
Oh, fuck!
Oh, nice, okay.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Thank god for the dice!
Oh, not the rocks.
No!
She got confused.
Me too.
I'm also very confused.
Oh!
Oh god, I need yourself.
I need yourself.
Oh, nice.
Oh, she does three damage?
That's fine.
Oh, this is not fine.
Oh god, there's so much.
Stop!
Oh my god.
That's secure.
Right?
Your daughter was harder than you.
That's right.
Sam the retired old woman.
And Sam the retired granny.
I struggled harder than your fucking daughter.
And she's just made a silk.
How did Lace?
Because she was impoverished.
reading she knew when i was gonna die she had my 20-year plan ready
she knew i was gonna graduate she knew when she knew which retirement home i was gonna go to she she knew in everything
all right yay i did it i saved the world I did it, everyone.
I saved... I saved Farloom!
Yay!
Oh my god, and I get six legs?
Let's go.
How is getting six legs a bad ending?
More hands to hold swords.
More hands to hold needles.
You met under new management?
Even better!
Finally!
I can be queen!
That means I got pro- How is that bad ending?
I got promoted.
I-
Now I'm literally royalty.
Yay!
I got promoted.
I see that as a win.
I don't understand how that could be a bad ending.
Congrats for the bad ending.
ending.
Nero, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
It's crazy.
The Grat- Silk Grandma was actually easier than Lace.
All these bosses, okay, the endgame bosses are so much easier than the fucking the journey to get there.
Never mind, you deserve this ending.
But Largus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat.
True ending run when.
I mean, I could- All right, well, I feel like I did finished i did get an ending pretty quick i did not i legit did not expect to like be this close to the end all right is it worth doing act three is
it worth it though
24 hours the token to be fair i did farm though so yeah we're not doing that yeah okay well we'll try and do as much as we can to unlock the truant the act three then what do i need to do to unlock act three
i afk too also like i access it okay i think the 24 hours is not accurate because i afk a lot i put the game open four or five wishes complete so i just need to do four or five wishes Talk to the grandpa or...
I do not need all of the fleas.
I feel like a lot of people still don't really know what you need for it.
Oh hey!
You made it!
The little...
Sharma!
Hmm?
Oh hi there!
I was hoping when we hear, Red Maiden.
Rising at last to the heights of the shadow.
And we want so many of you did it!
You made it!
the pilgrimage there's a blessing indeed yes a blessing your voice belies some hesitation i believe little pilgrim you have seen now the reality of this broken place what do you make of it truly i mean do not doubt me judge me a daughter that said as a holy place be resplendent and vassing on my wildest hopes but yet around all it aches with silence and i see suffering in the shadows whenever i peer too deeply fear and pain Why were these things allowed into your paradise?
And my brothers and sisters not yet earned their holy reward?
This time.
Played by Na Na Na Na Na Na Na Na Na Na Na Na Na Na Na Shut up!
Shh!
Be quiet!
I am here for Shurma!
Don't change her voice with your moaning!
All your work and look they keep arriving.
It's bugs a plenty up here now.
hapless weak but alive they are we're scared and weak they seem to me it's hard knowing these few have survived safe for your care that's your work bell ringer not my ring ain't helping i hope they recognize your efforts because i ain't providing much i need one for fighting in that choir and their pins ever come calling okay so what do i do to get act three i can't believe they ruined the song with their moaning I'm like,
I'm not playing my violin for you.
Okay, you out 22 fleas.
How many fleas have I even saved?
Oh, hunt club choir bugs.
Oh, okay, we gotta grab that.
Whose quest was this?
I don't even know when I...
I don't even know when I got those.
Alright.
Get to the last place.
He is optional.
Okay, that's good to know.
Ow.
I forgot about this.
All right.
We'll see how many quests we can... wishes we can do.
All right, here.
Are you the choir?
Wait, are these choir bugs?
I can't tell.
I don't know which ones are the choir.
These.
Requireable.
What do they look like?
Grab this stuff.
What do they look like again?
Oh, is it these guys?
No.
Or is it them?
Oh my god.
Oh, there he is.
Okay, this is what he looks like.
Okay, choir club.
Oh, here he is.
Nice.
All right.
Where's your body?
There you go.
Okay, I just gotta reset.
Wait, oh my, okay.
Wait, why are you naked?
He had clothes under there.
What the fuck?
You had nothing underneath?
Holy shit.
What are these guys considered wise?
No, they're not.
Don't laugh at him.
He just wants to be free.
He spent so long journey.
This is his reward.
His reward?
We're making it to Citadel.
He doesn't have to wear pants.
He doesn't have to wear clothes anymore.
He gets to be naked and free.
Alright, we just gotta kill that one guy.
Hello.
Wait, let me kill him.
first here.
I'm coming for you!
Get over here!
Nice.
Alright, there's one over here, too.
Oh, shit.
Are you fucking kidding?
Okay, that's not fair.
I think she's also...
I can also...
take her clothes too.
What does she look under there?
Oh my gosh, they're all naked.
No wonder everybody wanted to make the pilgrimage.
They all want to be naked.
Okay, I can't take his clothes.
Not the best spot.
I don't even know where to farm.
I just randomly went here.
Oh, here!
This is a farm spot.
Alright.
Give me your clothes.
Nice.
Oh, I took all his clothes.
Yeah, we're being so faithful.
You will be free.
Wake up!
Can't sleep on your job.
No slacking allowed.
Alright.
Or a chamber.
Okay.
I'm just killing him for money, too.
Let him sleep.
If I have to work, he has to work, guys.
It's simply equality.
Yoink, my clothes now.
Actually, I'll go down here.
Oh, nice.
Yoink.
Fire cloak.
Joink.
All right.
That is...
We're almost out.
We're almost...
We almost have all the clothes.
God, it's so unlucky that I had to fall into the snow.
How am I supposed to take his clothes now?
How will he be free?
Free from the restraint of clothing.
Oops.
Alright, reset.
I keep impelling him.
It's his own fucked up groundhog day.
This is my farm spot.
Ow.
Locked my head accidentally.
Alright, I just gotta get him out of here.
It's time!
Ring, ring, ring!
laundry i'm here to do your laundry ma'am it's weird that you only have okay this time this time i won't impel him in the spike there we go now i can take his clothes there oh there you go now he's fully naked look at that all spread out where's the other one all right nice
What?
Okay, I was gonna say.
How did she interrupted my attack?
I should be close, right?
How many more do I have?
Oh, nice.
I got it.
Alright, back I go.
Whee!
It's a little weird that the grandpa wants pre-worn cloaks.
I don't know what he's gonna do with them.
It is a little weird, but I don't ask questions.
I'm just here for Act 3.
What is the grandpa gonna do with that?
Blow the pilgrims that aren't dead.
Sir, I've opened the way above these halls and bested a white knight that stood as guardian.
Cal the monarch, she claimed herself at the end, and as she suggested, it's true.
A being born purely from silk woven tight.
feet is possible.
I've seen life woven from silk before, but tiny, transient, never like this.
Aye, bell-ringer, you slain a marvel indeed.
Well, flogged, marveled at least.
Wanted to keep far from she was, at least for us mortal sorts.
Look of a child and mind to match.
For hers been up wondering the citadel longer and most, even with long silence.
Wait for you, keep around, it's true.
Might as see herself this place protector, cleaving clean as quiet she did.
Of course.
Quiet moment.
Most crossing her path found a painful end from her pin.
I'd be saying thanks for the slaying.
With all the other husks now awoke in the range.
A bug's chance ain't grown by much.
Wait, whose quest was it?
Oh, there you go.
Fire cloak.
Yay!
Wish granted.
Okay, I got money.
Alright.
I don't have a...
Oh, is that so dear?
How old you are?
You should know, though.
This old pilgrim has their sights cleanly trained on you.
Nothing gets old Jubalaya.
Who's sleeping?
I just hear that.
Oh, hey!
It's you!
It's Garmon and Zaza!
Very meaning again, Sir Knight.
I see this bell has drawn you two towards his safety.
I'm sorry.
Who would have guessed, sister?
A safe corner hidden so high that top firelooms, curses, clown.
Our fair village may have fallen, but for these fellows, it is sacred if you are honored charges us to keep them safe.
Our hoaryland shall raise for them.
After some rest, of course.
Hold fast your new charge, Garmin.
See, these both survive, and know I am in time near to get down this curse at its core.
There's Garmin and Zaza!
Alright, so what do we have?
Oh, wait, we should actually return this first how many wishes am i missing oh talk to sherma for another wish all right sherma what do you want this place is holy yes by way of the suffering our fellow pilgrims so many are hurt and exhausted your doubts and worries will not heal them little one if you had aid your fellow you can start by dressing your wounds the simple rags found around the settlement will do for bandages oh that's an excellent idea red maiden normally i think a song with a fist but yes more direct action is certainly needed and a citadel itself shall provide the materials praise me to this whole use of holy lands wait what she's not gonna give you a quest you're not brothers and sisters and we work hard and keep our faith the city citadel will provide for us i have no doubt okay you mean i will provide for you guys who is the one that's paying for your citadel's taxes right now Oh,
gotta leave.
I'm literally paying for, like, the entire citadel.
The long one.
This guy?
You say, close sister.
Then husband crawling with husk.
Or you only bring death, pointed, and painful.
She doesn't know.
What do you mean?
This wishboy was, like, we need $400.
Oh, if only someone could give these poor pilgrims $400.
If only.
and it was me.
It was me.
I was the one that gave them $400.
There could... Anyone else could have given them $400, but they waited for me.
It wasn't a novice donation.
It could have been anyone.
And they're like, yay, praise the Citadel for providing for us.
Yay, I wish granted.
Oh.
Nice.
New mask.
Oh, look at that.
Another $400.
There you go.
Wish granted.
I don't even know how many wishes I've done.
I don't think any one of us have been keeping track.
Yeah, it doesn't even tell me.
Oh, wait, there he goes.
All right, let's count.
How many wishes do I need?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, 31.
I've done 31.
All right.
How to open the Bellheart's house?
How to open that?
Here.
How to open the Bellheart's house?
Is it this house up here?
Pavel.
Who the fuck is Pavel?
Oh, leave and come back.
Okay.
This guy?
in these terrible times it's rare not to see any wish granted not to see such care come from a stranger what i simply unheard of i've seen a scale of suffering route across farloom pavel i'll admit fulfilling these requests may do little to affect the cause even so i found it a worn cast so you need another a small worth of it i'd almost forgotten what the fuck is pavel what the fuck is pavel I wonder if only I know Who that guy is Hmm I guess I'll never know where he is Guys Welcome,
welcome Bellar, glory is coming in very very safe See you while before you begin your final climb You'll need to talk to a fleas Because your cavern Aerovan needs to be moved again Okay, so how do I open the How do I open this?
How do I fix this oh go to another bench oh my god i am lord oh my god that's why i was like why is this song so familiar it's literally i am lord la la la that's where he's going it's literally the same dude dude
wondering.
I was like, why the fuck every time I see these things, and I was like, this sounds so familiar.
Oh my god, I gotta donate.
Yeah, it's from so far.
La la la.
I am Lord.
Wait, do I not have more oh, I do.
How much do I need?
Yeah, I don't have that.
Oh, fuck it.
I'll just do the I open my wallet.
Wait, what were it?
Is everybody?
Why am I donating to a... Oh, wait, no, there's people here.
I was gonna say, why am I donating to a dead town?
There's like five people that lives here.
Five people live here.
Like, who needs this?
They do not need this.
Oh my god, and I accidentally used my shard to make my tools.
I...
Okay.
These guys should be easy to kill.
I'll farm it Oh my god This is gonna take forever to farm
They need whatever What are they gonna do with 420?
I'll just give them Food There's only Five people that live here What are you gonna do It's faster to farm money and buy them I don't even know know where to buy them that's the thing who's sold do i have like who sells them
any merchant yeah but but have i not bought all of them does the bellhart have some i don't remember i bought all of them
oh forge daughter has some oh yeah i forgot about here i haven't seen it in a long time oh it's Okay, I thought it was like a one-time thing.
I didn't realize it's unlimited.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's buy the bundles.
Oh yeah, there it is.
Alright, how many do I need?
I'll buy two stacks.
I would allow money anyway.
Oh, I need one more.
Alright.
Oh, yeah, here.
Can I have my house now?
Miss Traveler, thank you to your valiant contributions.
Our little town's starting to feel like it's old self again.
Homes have been hoisted and there's shiny spires.
Hasina changes myself, Pavel.
This place didn't hear my contributions have not been in vain.
Thank God they didn't waste my money on some...
meaningless thing like pokemon cards thank god i'm so happy they didn't embezzle my money and indeed your generosity is a guide for others we've only one thing now solely missing bugs what is a town about its residents age scarcity deadly thread the heart is beset by endless ills now there's just us remaining few as you met in recognition of your noble efforts and That's one step to solving the problem.
I decree a grand gift should be given.
A bell home.
Oh my God.
A free house.
I don't have to.
Oh my God.
I hope there's like no.
No red flags with it.
Do I have to pay the property tax?
I read that like if you're gifted a mansion, it's easier to sell than to live in it because of property taxes.
And so I hope there's no like exception with exceptions.
here yeah quote-unquote free you have to pay like all the taxes for it a place to reflect a bed to lay in it's king up there at the top beside our gold pin master to me again I have no plans to settle Pavel but for now my task in Parfarlum remains and while it does a resume prove useful of course of course Your fortitude impressed us all.
I have trouble ever descends on you.
It surely won't hurt to have a resident warrior.
No sack now.
Yay!
I have a house now.
And I have to pay a 70% property tax.
Even though I don't live here.
Yay!
I locked a bell home.
Yippee!
But look.
I'll get how comfy.
bed i'm not homeless anymore guys i still sit on it okay i'm not even sleeping on the bed why would i buy furniture at the shop it's not like i live here it's finally a forged bell madam unfortunately i have a safe space to rest even my seer may be short have it long with this i've been holding on to some fine goods out cozy up your home this stuff ain't for the riffraff whining through but fellow bellhard deserves the finest Like,
what am I gonna do?
I'm not even gonna live here.
I didn't buy a spa?
There's a spa here?
There's no spa.
I can have a desk.
Oh, I do.
Sleep on it?
Good.
Alright, where do we go now?
Oh, not yet?
What's that word called?
Like, um...
Like, when you get something, but there's, like, There's like red flags around it, like with a cost.
There's a word for that.
Oh yeah, the fleas are at Graymore.
A scam.
Yeah, with strings attached.
There's strings attached to it.
Okay, the fleas are down here.
Wait, I could have...
minute.
What the fuck am I doing?
I could have went there from Bellar.
What the fuck?
I was like, wait a minute.
They're like literally right there.
Why the fuck is that?
Okay.
Yeah, I could have gotten ready.
Alright.
Where the fuck am I?
Hello.
Oh, I should refill this.
Might as well.
Oh, chair.
Who was it?
Who do I talk to?
Him?
Is he the main guy?
Look here.
All these lively fleas flock to our caravan.
Thanks to you and our hunting, our numbers grow grand.
Mayhaps in time we should grow to match even those caravans of our fabled past.
To see so many safe is a welcome chair suggests you're fine steward for the swelling truth such kind words miss hornet how lucky we're to find a friend so far but now we must away these moors have been our hosts long enough it's time to climb and hoist towards dry your case your friend the fleas would you join us on the next journey yeah let's travel the flea caravan oh well wonderful well wonderful the fleas will be overjoyed to share this next journey with our favorite companion.
Moshka.
Oh.
Oh, they put me in the dog the doggy carriage.
Okay, that's cool.
I'm just like, okay.
I have all this flea hair on me now.
Another journey complete.
And a new high spot for a rest.
Upon the doorstep of that mighty Citadel, no less.
You're not a Yeah, I think Hornet's a flea person I won't be surprised He seems like a flea person What's the What's the buggy equivalent of a cat in this game?
Chat Are you a Are you a flea person?
Or a worm person?
Oh, are you a flea person or a grub person?
Oh yeah, the grubs are cats!
The grubs are cats and the fleas are dogs.
Maybe I should ask, maybe I should change, ask, um, ask the person that made Doki Bug to change it into a flea.
It's fortunate that all your companions survive the trek, the master.
Oh, I thought I said it is, okay, I thought I said it is unfortunate.
It's fortunate that the howling rise beside and the tangled wood before it have both cleaned the lives of countless bugs.
Indeed.
you the perilous perilous ascent maybe it was your company that brought us luck miss hornet it surely puts us fleas at ease to have you and your weapon riding close ah and before the road steals you away from us again allow me to offer you a humble gift one of the little ones found the pear artifact while digging above in the sands a spawning cold sort of thing i see no use in it for we fleas so of course we are all too pleased eager even to bestow it upon our dear friend
Don't you hate it when you give someone a gift and they start levitating?
Here we shall remain for a time, assorted, and pray that more lost fleas find a way to us.
Alright, how many more lost fleas do I have to find?
Isn't that ground your gears when that happens?
Alright.
I need to find...
I don't even remember...
Where is the fucking...
Because I need to go to...
Okay, there it is.
Alright.
There is.
My fast travels down there.
Oh my god.
You know...
Oh my god, he's alive now!
Oh wait, no, he always was alive.
JK.
Sorry, I got confused.
Okay.
Over here.
All right.
Let's just sit down here for a sec.
Ada!
Uh...
Grand Bellway...
I don't even know how many fleas I've saved.
I feel like I've saved so many.
I've lost count.
Man, did I...
Oh yeah, I forgot to...
Oh, I forgot to donate.
Did I...
Wait, did I not already donate?
Oh, I didn't.
I went to Bellheart to look at my new home.
I forgot about that.
Alright, time to grant another wish.
Oh, I forgot to...
I was like, how?
I forgot to unpack this one.
Alright, here you go.
My five villagers.
I hope you don't die out.
How would they repopulate the village?
point it's just gonna be inbreeding how this is a problem yeah no okay to have us to have a to avoid inbreeding yet those have a specific amount of like citizens or there will be a problem they come here to eat
Alright, let's go to...
Oh, there's so many, like...
There's a lot of back and forth.
What's that word?
There's a lot of, like...
You have to go back.
You have to go back in certain areas.
Backtracking!
There's so much backtracking here!
Holy fuck!
Alright.
Where did she go?
Wait, where's Shrema?
Shrema?
Where does Shurma go?
Shurma?
Oh.
I have new watches.
Do you want more money?
I just gave you four.
Oh my god.
Remember when Shurma was like, praise the Citadel for giving in to your, for supporting.
I'm, it's me.
It's me.
I'm here to fund more stuff for.
the citadel all right shermo is traveling to the citadel's white word oh okay it's down here i am the i'm the citadel sponsor how do i get to white word okay i gotta go down here so much backtracking oh my gosh down here all right i don't even live here and have to pay for their taxes all right time to save shermo
I should make- I should get a statue.
Oh yeah, I should grab this chair.
Just in case.
Or emergency.
I need money anyway.
Alright.
Oh, I should- I didn't explore here yet.
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
Alright, who's that?
Tocky.
Or like above me.
Are you up here?
Why don't you like my music?
Oh, shit.
I was trying to dash.
Oh, it's you!
Get out of here!
Oh, they stole my money!
Okay.
It's the thieves.
My money!
Wait, that's it?
Nothing else here?
I was glad there was more stuff.
Oh, did I get...
Did it give me a silk eater?
Oh, it did!
I didn't even notice that.
Can't believe it.
They robbed me.
That's illegal.
Where are my...
Where are the butt cops?
Oh, they're all dead.
I forgot.
They're all dead.
Oh, wait.
I should have...
kill them for money more.
Alright.
And this way.
Wee!
Call bug 9-1-1!
And then down.
Wee!
Alright, Shurama should be here.
Hello!
Alright, that means there's a body.
foot maybe here bug one one sherma
sherma where are you
sherma that funny right now i'm gonna save you sherma oh it's right?
There?
Sherma?
Oh hey.
Oh there it is.
Oh I got your scent.
Bye.
Oh shit.
Red explodes.
I know the smell.
I know the smell of Sherma and it's not creepy.
I'm just Doing my job.
This way.
Look, I was just really worried for her.
So I memorized what she smelled like.
I was worried for her life.
I read her my maiden.
Have no fear.
This only eye.
Sure, ma.
I found healing supplies.
But on the way back collapsed.
And heard moaning from the dark.
Oh, how thankful I am to see.
Don't worry, hold your gratitude, little one.
The dead are stirring.
I got this.
Never go full silk.
You know what?
Oh, there you go.
This is what I'm doing with that guy.
These guys are annoying.
Easy.
I'm a hero now about those taxes that I have to pay for the citadel can I get a tax cut after that I should get tax cuts after that all right maiden sorry to alert you in such danger and those poor bugs bewitched by the thread no shins could possibly warn such a fate your pity is not misplaced but better suited for another time for now you should look to your own care Oh,
yes, I should get those healing supplies back to the pilgrims on the above.
My brother and sister have waited long enough.
Yeah.
All right.
Wait, was Tema here?
Did I miss it?
Oh, yeah, I first tried it.
Zero damage.
So because, you know, Not only did I first try it, but I did no damage.
I should be allowed to pick the shoe.
Can you safely make your way back to the settlement, little one?
I could escort you if you need be.
Oh, yes, I am.
Oh, no.
I lay no more of my troubles upon you, Red Maiden.
The way it cleared, I can return under my own guidance.
After all, what's another pilgrimage, eh?
Uh-huh.
Oh, and I found something for you as well.
I found it buried amongst the broken relics down there in the darkness.
Glowing with a pale light.
It's an odd-looking thing.
Not exactly holy-seeming.
I would be honored you accepted it all the same.
I also first tried the final boss, too.
But I feel like she wasn't hard, though.
Compared to Lace, Lace was the complicated, the...
Was the difficult one.
Lace, you know...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
She's crying.
Sad song.
Sad Serba.
Yeah, that's right.
Keep singing, terrifying.
Keep singing through the tears.
I like it.
She's here.
Hi, Redo.
Keep singing.
I'll let you know when I'm done, Sherma.
This rings my heart.
Don't bully it.
I have so much silk, Sherma.
Stop!
Let him stop!
Yes,
more.
More!
Oh!
Alright.
Guess that's enough singing, Sherma.
You're lucky.
You're lucky I have limited silk.
I would have made you kept going.
I want more.
I'm greedy.
This is the worst thing you've done on stream so far.
Alright, this way.
Toki, please.
Alright.
Where do I have to go now?
Let's see.
Guys, where do we have to go now?
I'm a lost.
I'm a...
Ow!
What the fuck?
He's like, This is for sure, Mom!
Oh yeah, you're right.
I almost forgot.
I have to...
Do I need more?
Okay, I need 500.
I can grab that easily.
500 is not too hard.
Alright.
See?
So halfway there.
Well, we need 50 more.
But we're basically almost halfway there.
Where am I?
Wee!
My favorite farm is...
Oh, 550?
That was 5.
I'm just farming here.
Uh...
I need...
10.
more we got it here there you go this is basically where i spent like an hour to get three grand i spent my time farming this one area all right we're trying
mr broken bot thank you the super chat thank you thank you The CIA's worst thing was waterboarding, but Doki makes you sing until she is happy.
But she will never be happy.
That's right.
You'll never ever make me satisfied.
My expectations are too high.
You'll never reach my expectations.
Welcome back, Red Maiden.
And thank you again for coming to my aid.
I'm no healer, but with the supplies we found in the ward below, even my unlawful claws can ease the suffering of brothers and sisters.
Boy, you don't have a degree.
I don't think I trust you.
Do you even know how to clean the wounds?
You don't just pour it disinfected into the wound, Tremah.
What if the wound is infected?
What?
he has a he has a degree in faith he just believes hard enough it's like it's like if i it's like if you were a plague doctor you're like don't worry i could cure the plague we'll just need more leeches
that such darkness could creep into this most holier places even though we pilgrims kept our promises promise to ascend i have we have silk it's okay Just keep pouring silk into it.
I will confess.
I wonder in the meaning of it all.
But enlightenment does not come easily or all at once.
I should just continue my task in the meantime.
All these marvelous healing supplies.
Should at least are some proof of this.
I got you the healing supplies.
It's not just the citadel.
All right.
Where do we go?
And who saved his life when he was trying to get the supplies?
Everywhere.
There I think, I feel like Shurama's idea of like how to be a doctor is just, don't worry, we'll just rub hand sanitizer on the wound.
You'll be fine.
Memorium.
How do we get there?
Or is that?
I feel like I've done all the quests I have in my inventory.
Yeah.
Go left?
But where?
Here?
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Up and left.
Go left and up?
Go to the hallway with the big bulky dudes.
Oh, here.
Here?
Okay.
I'll go to the room with the big bulky men.
Oh.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh, where am I?
Oh.
What's this?
What is this place?
This is new.
Here is established by holy consent of the conductors.
The memoriam of Fire Loom.
What is remembered is never lost.
It's a mosque, you guys.
Is it a zoo?
Oh, it is!
Oh, wait, that's bad.
Isn't that just like...
That's just like...
Jail.
Guys, a human zoo is just a jail.
What were the crimes?
Holy shit, what the?
The crime of existing.
Jesus!
Okay, these guys are annoying.
I don't like them.
What the fuck?
I'm...
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Squint.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, no, that one definitely did some form of crime.
Thank God they locked him up.
Holy shit.
I'm so happy he got locked up.
No, he absolutely deserved to be caged.
Do I go upward?
Okay, well, I don't know.
Up or down?
Assume I'll go down, actually.
There you go.
Maps the right side?
This right or up right?
Oh, here.
This right.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my!
Okay, wait.
Oh, I'm $5.
Does Canadian want to spend?
Paying me $5.
It's not fair.
They don't even have money.
They don't understand the concept of money.
Oh my god, I'm broke.
These bugs don't even understand what money is.
And nothing even has money here.
It's so fucked up.
I hate the citadel.
No, I need to kill you.
You're still.
Your existence hurt me.
I don't know why.
I look at the map.
I can't see nothing.
Let's wait.
We don't need the map.
We don't need it.
Oh my god.
I got greedy.
Oh, God, not these guys.
These guys are...
I hate these guys.
I hate these ones so much.
I don't need no GPS.
I have a built-in GPS right here.
And it's my mind.
Is that it?
It has to be a secret here, right?
Oh, it's here.
Oh, God.
I hate these guys so much.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I think this is my most hated regular bug.
How the fuck do I kill this guy?
Jesus, he takes up the whole space!
He's so chonky!
Yeah, it's like pure advanced geometry, right?
Okay, I know how to kill him when I'm up here.
Oh!
Never mind.
I know how to do it And then I proceed to fall down Condemn fails Memory loss Excise outer Maintain inner Shellwood status Unstained Sustain Remember Maryland status Critical remember What?
It's just a lower room
What do I do in the lower room?
What?
Damn.
Oh no.
No, the geometry man.
Geometry!
He's lore in the lore room.
God damn fucking, okay, now I can go back down.
I can go back down and grab five dollars real quick.
Let me grab five dollars.
There we go.
Okay, now I have the money.
Okay, oh my god, and I have to, I just remembered, I have to, I have to go all the way to where I died.
Where did I die?
The question is, where?
Oh my god, I don't remember.
Okay, we go straight.
Yeah, the solution is really easy.
I just gotta rob someone.
I think it was right here.
Yeah, I went high ground.
Okay.
And that went into the waterlands.
God damn it, I forgot to fucking...
Drown in the water.
Thank God.
That's right.
Drown.
I don't care.
As long as he dies, that's all that matters.
You know what?
I'm already committed.
Let's go here.
Oh, where is here?
Man, if only I have a way to figure that out.
Oh, elevator.
To imagine, I just used it.
I just used it on the elevator.
I'm going to grab the map.
If only I had a map, what would I, what should I do?
I was this close to using it.
Alright.
Yes.
Go left to unlock.
Did I not unlock it already?
Oh, this guy is easy.
Or did...
Oh, wait.
Where is it?
Oh my god, it didn't hit that wall.
I didn't realize that was a breakable wall.
Okay.
Where are they like examining like looking at these is it like those Wait, no, these are the windows.
Oh Oh, oh my god, you're still alive.
I leave I was gonna say like how are they even like looking at the zoo?
Oh How do I get up there?
Oh There you go.
Looks like I see it.
There you go.
Last one.
Top left.
Oh, I lost...
Okay, I sort of lost it, but...
Um...
I lost it.
Is it this one?
Yeah.
Um...
Um, uh, is this?
No elk.
Or is it in the middle?
Oh, I lost it.
And then the top right, yeah?
This one?
Oh, I lost it.
Uh, okay.
And this one, right?
Enable Rewind, who can tell you?
I guess.
Guys, okay, and then center, right?
Is this the center, you're like?
My gut says maybe.
No?
Yeah?
Oh, mayhaps?
Okay, uh...
Oh, I fucked up.
Oh, my God, you fuckers.
I forgot already.
Um, um.
Okay.
Oh, my.
There we go.
Yay!
I thought it could reset from the very beginning, so I got scared.
What did I unlock?
Oh, I got a car cart.
And so I was like, oh, no.
Okay, and then we go left.
I guess we're not unlocking the elevator.
Oh my god, the fucking... He comboed me, but all he did was just exist.
He just existed, sir.
Uh, this way.
I don't know.
I had to look up to see how... I had to look at my inventory to see how much I have.
I'm just gonna skip this guy.
There's no reason to try and kill him.
It's even worth activating the elevator?
What's here?
Hello?
Who lives here?
Oh.
It's fucked up.
Is there anything here?
What the fuck?
I...
What?
How do I...
Oh.
Are you here?
Fuck!
Okay.
That was on me, to be fair.
I got confused.
I- ah, what?
I think I might be dead.
Oh.
No!
I don't have my double jump!
Oh, this is...
I'm gonna...
Oh my god, I almost ran in here.
I'm gonna go back down and sit on the bench.
Oh my god, I thought that was like toxic water.
And I thought I died.
I'm gonna head downstairs now.
Oh!
The baby, God.
Oh my god, the fucking baby, God.
See?
I just, I never expect a baby.
Whoever, whoever expects the baby.
No one ever expects the baby.
Where did...
Oh my gosh.
Of all things.
Why was the baby there?
Who let this child be here?
Where's his mom?
I killed him.
I forgot.
Yes, Doki.
Because you made them into orphans, remember?
I forgot.
I killed the parents.
Nobody ever expects the baby Inquisition.
Okay, we gotta grab the shortcut.
I don't even have to go there.
Wait, actually?
I'd never done this area yet.
I just realized.
Let's stay here.
Oh!
Oh my god, okay.
Wait, I have an idea.
There we go.
What is this?
Oh, it's a memory locket.
Oh, we need that.
I have to do this all.
Oh my god, please tell me to just shortcut out of here.
Oh, I have to do all of this again.
I'll just kill him first.
Alright, nice.
Yeah, because I was like, wait, I haven't done the far left.
But the far left doesn't seem to have anything.
I can't heal.
It's fine.
I won't be fooled by the baby.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm still...
I still won't be fooled by the baby.
Get out of here.
It wasn't a baby that hurt me this time.
It doesn't count.
Instead, it was an inanimate object that never moved.
That doesn't mean it's worse.
How?
Okay, there you go.
Oh, it was just for silk.
What's this?
He's shaking his booty.
I want yourself.
I'm gonna smack...
Oh, shit.
there we go and it's still not enough silk oh oh my gosh
what's over here
what is over here oh it's another shortcut the baby was just eating and i'm like you all right oh i got full heart all right where do we go Got a full heart.
Now where do we go?
Go to back to a map room in Memor...
Mem...
What?
Memorium?
I have to go back to the map room.
Why?
Oh, I missed that room?
Okay.
Memorium.
That's over here.
Oh, I should sit on the bench.
I forgot about that.
Alright.
He should be back, right?
Oh, no.
Top of the memoriam?
Oh!
I didn't go top right.
I didn't realize that.
It's right here.
He's just eating.
I was like, you die now.
How dare you just eat in front of me?
There's some people who haven't been eaten yet.
People in Africa are starving and you're just eating?
Oh, I don't like this.
Alright.
That was a little too close.
I'll go here.
Oh, I want to grab this.
Maturium.
Where the fuck is Maturium?
Okay, now I'm up here.
Oh, silk!
Yay!
Free silk.
Oh, hidden water.
is all right yeah oh there it is what is over here hello oh my god you wanted me to go oh my god you wanted me to go into this hidden room you fucking
oh god this has to be the item that they they're like Let's see if we can bait her to go into this hidden trap.
I knew it.
Okay, vault vessel.
Okay, it's another 12.
It's worth it.
Like, how do we trick Doki to go into this trap?
Sometimes I'm too fast for my own good.
Oh.
It's chungus flea.
Hello, flea.
Who's I'm good for?
I'm here to save you.
Oh.
Oh my god.
You're good for nothing.
Bad dog.
Oh my god.
You're a bad boy.
Oh I did it.
Oh.
Savage flea fly.
Why is he so big you see the other fleas were just little chihuahuas and he's like the golden retriever oh look at the journal entry someone's been a bad boy i will never get so large and marvelous a flea existed i'm pleased it's our sense by the strike a killing blood jesus christ briefly consumed by anger after it's been caged for so long Yeah,
he's a Saint Bernard.
Yay, we did it!
Alright, where do we go now?
Yeah.
Fuck this kid.
Map room?
Okay, let me...
Alright, I'm gonna sit on the bench.
Bench time!
There you go.
Oh no, he actually... Oh shit!
I didn't think he'd do damage.
Like, why am I so weak against children?
It's literally a child.
And it does, like, 10 damage, like, 5 damage on me or some shit.
What do I do in Map Room?
Good roll.
It's in the ceiling.
Oh, this?
Oh, there it is.
Hello.
It's outside.
Oh my god, I can go outside.
Do I just go outside?
This looks like a boss fight.
Did you guys took me to a boss fight again?
You guys took me to a boss fight, didn't you?
Hello?
Is anybody here?
Oh, no, it's just item.
Thank God.
Wait, it's just a shark bundle.
Maybe go outside for a shark bundle?
What?
Yeah, I see that.
There you go.
I got the passage.
Oh, my God, it's more parkour.
Okay.
There we go.
Parkour!
Is I go this way?
Wow, I can't believe it was a dead end, guys.
I can't believe it.
Wow, that's so unfortunate.
That this tunnel was just a dead end.
Oh my god, it's required!
You see, I don't know if you're fucking with me, too.
Just to give me more...
Just to give me pain.
Oh my god.
Just so I can suffer.
Yo, get back in there.
It's not over.
Until I say it's over.
What's here?
Jesus!
What the?
Oh my god, this place sucks.
This place sucks.
They're so tanky.
They're actually so tanky, too.
I don't understand this area.
Okay.
Oh my god, that again!
Oh, I did it again!
Ah,
good roll.
This area is so serious.
I hate this area.
Oh my god.
Why would you take me here?
What did I do to deserve it?
I don't understand.
I thought I've been a good boy.
What did I do to deserve this?
Wait, you're- wait, what?
Why do I- you guys were friendly before?
Oh my god, I'm done.
I'm not okay right now.
Wee!
Bye.
It's fine.
Oh my god, how do I...
How do I...
There you go.
I hurt him.
And then I accidentally fell.
And oh my...
It's okay.
I'm so scared I'm gonna get hit by it.
There you go.
Wait, what's down here?
Oh my god, I thought I hit it!
Oh my god, it's just...
I...
Fuck you!
Okay.
I got double hit.
I don't know what it is about them.
I just...
It's like those angler fishes.
Just makes me wanna...
I just wanna, like, go up to it.
wait how much does the money give me it gives me 30.
it gives me 30.
it gives me ring ring ring please oh my god i i don't even have enough for a fucking bench i there's no there's none none of these people give money
i'm literally for up And it was...
It didn't even...
I swear to God.
I don't even have enough for our map.
That's the worst part.
Wait, I should...
I haven't...
Pull me!
Okay, I had to have him pull me.
Oh, tell me they have money.
thank god thank god this is free oh thank god it's the little things in life oh did he come back how did you respond
okay what's over here oh
oh my god this okay it god i just want money nice that i'm a watch that's right that's funky right
where are the money
okay secret secret tunnel secret tunnel i think the worst part is that because i have no money i have the most insane runback oh god the runback is so bad here how does this take me
oh this is so bad are you fucking kidding me okay that's fine that's oh my god it's not fine it's
Let's go grab money.
Let's just grab money real quick.
How much did I need?
I don't even remember.
There you go.
How much money do I need?
140.
Okay.
I don't even care.
care.
I have shards for days.
I had 60, right?
How much did I have?
Where's the chair?
Okay, it's up here.
How much do I have to farm, chat?
Because I don't know.
84?
Alright.
I don't care.
Oh my god, oh my, okay, maybe I should start carrying.
Maybe...
Oh, is it worth...
Oh, I don't want to use this.
Okay, I should start carrying.
I...
Alright.
Okay.
One more guard.
There we go.
I'll farm one more just to be safe.
I don't care if I'm wasting my...
If I'm wasting my shards, I don't care.
Should get 120?
Uh...
Should get 160?
Wait, how many do I have?
Okay, I just got 160.
Alright, it's time.
Time for help.
There you go.
This way.
Back again.
Back to hell.
I go.
Alright, at least I can afford the bench now.
Thanks fucking god.
Oh my god.
that decided to not follow his family.
Should have stuck with your family, sir.
I forgot about this parkour section.
Oh, the fucking snipe.
Because of course he did.
Alright, this way.
Okay.
Bench is here.
all right we're gonna grab the bench first
and then oh wait i don't know okay i can grab both of them nice wait where's the other bell okay thank god i was gonna say is i swear to god they have like a little puzzle be like you gotta grab all the bell you gotta find the last bell so we can you can use the chair i swear to god all right
You better come over here.
If I have to be here, you have to be here too.
You suffer with me in this cursed place.
Oh my god, I forgot.
I know he was just there.
But I forgot he existed.
He, like, disappeared for five seconds and I already forgot he was here.
Okay.
If he's not in front of me, he was not real.
There we go.
I'm like thinking, is there...
Yeah, because like I was like wondering, is there something up here?
Oh, I think it's just a...
It's just a shortcut, right?
So I don't have to fight that guy?
What's this?
Hello?
He's dead.
Oh, the key.
Oh, wait, I remember this key.
I don't know where it goes, but I remember it.
No, no!
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad, my beautiful silly.
Like, how?
Okay, who lives here?
Hello, sir.
What?
Jesus Christ, are you just like...
Bro, these all just dead...
Oh, hey.
I guess it's here.
Nice.
See, even a body...
If a body can be a bench, why don't I just do that all the time?
Are you okay, sir?
Like...
There's a lot of mud and rotten bodies here that you're just breathing in.
It's not good for your lungs.
Spider!
Your sensuous string...
It's similar.
Your tension has smelt strong.
Do I seem a threat to you?
This whole land keeps me cautious, tall one.
And your claws like to have much sharp use.
Yes, I kill gladly.
Bone leaf to feed my shell.
Oh, she laid eggs on all these dead bodies.
Oh, you're a meat.
Much sustenance it could grant, but too hard to pry.
Your long, false claws would slash back.
Good, so you can sense my skill as I yours, a true scent that we both shall live beyond our meaning.
You say, spider, my brood needs meat, much the organs of others.
Would you set off for your own?
Gifts the shells warm inside as we feast for my brood's birth meal?
All right, time to kill other bugs.
Yay, cannibalism!
No.
And I offer my own organs, Hunter.
Do I may bring the meat of the other slain?
Good, Spider.
Scorched, shredded, seared.
Bring it all.
Some of my tools compare the meat as you request.
I unfortunately find so very an arsenal within your lands.
My brood has not long till hatching, Spider.
Do your duty swift, and you shall cease reward for slaughter.
All right.
Seared organ Use tools to acquire organs of various Meats to hunt us Okay what tools do I use
What tools are these Doesn't even say Seared organ, shredded organ, skewered organ Are they kill bugs of the saw This one?
I don't have the fire tool Oh my god
Fire piercing and slash What other does What other does What does...
Saw, Flint, and Longpin.
Oh, okay.
Oh, this works too?
Okay, we'll do these two first.
Oh my god, this is a mission where it requires tools.
That's so awkward for me.
After I was like, I don't need tools.
I had plenty, I was like, I have plenty of shards.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
Let's see.
Alright, we have to kill these guys.
Okay, I don't ever use this one before.
Does this work?
Did that work?
Oh my god, he...
Oh my god, and I fell in the water!
Okay, he fell in the water and I fell in the water.
Okay, let's go.
back up what the fuck I hate this area so much that's right I'm gonna watch that's right fuck you okay he's just gonna take me closer to the top I need to get to the top and I swear to that I'm just gonna head to the top I'm leaving I'm not doing this in this area this area fucking sucks all right yeah it would be easier to farm it here they fly too much i'll just farm it here
there we go skewered
does he not give me hello i skewered you
yeah but i'll fight them normally i just want to do the huntress thing first oh poison killed it oh i see okay i'll take this off then i'm taking this out and just put that here okay wait what's this mirror when binding oh my god trubio
yeah what's wrong with the little bit of poison in your meat.
There you go.
Oh my god, that's a lot.
Yeah, what's wrong with a little bit of poison?
Okay, wait.
How much do I have to do?
Four out of ten.
Oh, that's fine.
I'll just farm these three.
Nice.
And there's one over here.
I might as well just grab them all.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Give me a second.
There you go.
I had to angle it.
I was like, wait a minute.
No!
I accidentally RB'd!
I'm sad.
I accidentally RB'd.
There was some juicy meat right here.
Some juicy meat that I couldn't grab.
Trurias, mirror explosion.
Oh, wait, let's try that.
I just have to bind, right?
How do I even use it?
Oh, okay, I don't have enough.
Never mind.
I don't have enough.
Alright.
Wait, do I have all of it?
I think that's 10.
Alright, now Jesus, that's so many.
Holy shit!
Oh my!
That's a lot of Shredded organs.
I did not.
I was like, oh my god, I need to farm 35, but it gives like so many.
Yeah, I actually shredded them.
Yeah, thank God Shred Drops multiple organs.
Alright, and then we gotta Try... What was it?
This one?
Yeah, Shredded is the easiest.
Okay.
I should kill out of this.
Stop jumping!
I wasted so many...
So many tools for that because he kept jumping.
Oh, don't worry.
Follow this.
All right.
Whoops.
How many was that?
I need... All right, one more run.
Wait, I could change how the saw works?
I didn't even know that.
I've just been using it normally.
That's a lie.
There's only one use.
Oh, not the saw?
Which one?
Oh!
The vessel can be thrown as a bowler for it or staked as a spear.
I'll throw it.
Fuck it.
Throwing is easier.
Okay.
Throwing seems a little easier.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, yes, it does do it.
Nice, Seared.
Okay.
That should be...
Okay, 35.
Alright.
One more.
Get over here, guys.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
I can stab it.
That's good.
I can also stab it on the ground.
Like, stab them with it and it counts.
Oh, I can hit it while it's in the ground and it moves.
Oh!
Let's get to know.
The other mode is easier.
Alright, I'll try it out.
Oh, I can't try it out.
I'll try out the next one.
God damn it, stop jumping!
That's it.
No!
It fell on the ground.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Oh my god, get over here!
Oh my god, I don't have any left he fell he fell in the water all right i'll try the other trap i have uh it's okay i have shards for emergencies okay i'm gonna take that away too
all right uh we'll grab this away just oh yeah all right let's see what how to use the bombs into my retirement fund okay yeah that was never mind you're right he's got this is easier wait no i i'm so sad he died from just he died from a concussion i'm so sad
there you go get behind he got concussion instead of the fire the impact all
right here you go
I don't know.
Two more.
That's fine.
There's two over here.
Alright, last one.
Get over here!
Alright, I'll leave you alive.
Tell the people what you saw.
Alright, wish updated.
Why don't you just angle for more speed?
Because I'm lazy.
Okay, now I can get my regular...
stuff saw boomerang poison no more Trubia all right back to the ducks we go back to the basement all
right at least it's not the bio whatever that shit actually sucked I don't want to go back there oh wait Chair.
I really don't want to go back to the pile or whatever.
So I'm glad, guys, right?
That it's not required, right?
Rackery?
Yeah, guys?
Yeah?
It's not required or anything, right?
Oh my god, I keep fucking standing into that goddamn stupid trap.
Uh-huh.
Never have to go back there.
Ha-ha.
All right.
Bench time.
You have them, Spider.
The smell is upon you.
All those organs rich prepared for feasting.
Yes, I did my job.
There's a buggy bug world out there.
You've done well, Spider.
meats my children will gorge and grow and better the organs of others than they feed upon your own yes one cannot be surprised for the spider to perceive the truth of my request child of one like you many times i've seen it similar they're born hungry with sharp tooth and claw and a birth craze your own meat would delight as much as another bugs this beast is a distraction and hopes to save your own shell oh she didn't want the bugs to eat the eat her like she didn't eater is that shameful a mother who would not sacrifice herself for children to grow strong is it wrong to want to want to witness their first flight their first hunt to see them killing and grow well i mean if they're if they eat you technically you get to witness them killing for the first time your choice is your own tall mother you won't be judged by me i've seen enough sacrifices I have no love for the act.
All I'm saying...
Oh, it's Lawn Claw.
Eh.
I mean, the poison, though.
The poison and the shard, the binding is just so much better.
I feel like...
Isn't it even cooler to see your kids eat you?
Like, you're...
Just before you die, you get to see your children eat you from inside out.
be an honor.
That'd be the last...
I swear to God.
I swear to fucking... Oh!
Like, okay.
I hate him.
God, I hate him so much.
I...
Get over here.
I'll kill you.
I don't care.
Oh my God, you fucker.
That is...
I'll still kill you.
I don't care.
I will kill him if it's the last thing I do.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god, I dodged it.
Oh, but I'm not fighting.
Any of these?
No!
It's okay.
I refuse to fight any of them.
I knew it.
I knew that was a secret passage.
I'm so...
What's over here?
Oh no!
Well it is over here.
I hate these, I hate them so much.
I hate them.
I don't know which one is.
I'm so paranoid right now.
Oh my nice, thank god.
The Reef of Purity.
What the fuck is that?
Oh my god, where's the bench?
I need a bench.
Why did they give it to me when I'm so far away?
Wait, what on the left?
Oh, this one?
Oh my god, it's so far.
Okay, I need to have him take me all the way up.
Okay.
Grab me.
What wall did I have to check?
Wait.
Wait, there's a wall?
Where's the wall?
Go left on the wall?
Oh, here?
Oh!
Oh, it's just money.
Okay, at least I have money before I lose it.
Ah, it's not!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, thank God.
It's a shortcut.
Oh, my.
You know, it's fine.
It's fine.
If I die to these guys, it's fine.
I'm just so...
I'm okay.
I...
It's okay.
Okay.
It's...
Oh, it's...
Oh, my God.
I dodged so much!
I doubled so much!
I...
Oh my god, and I sat down here!
Holy shit, I dodged everything just to still die.
I think I went through like actual nine circles of hell right there in that one area.
Get Eden get Eden.
Come on get Eden fly fly fly fly get Eden come on come on fly here come on come on That's it.
That's it.
Oh My god, I'm so scared actually nice That's all I want All right I'll equip it here What's the anti-magnet?
here it is uh get rid of the poison nature is so brutal okay thank god
yeah oh my gosh i don't have to be worried about the maggots anymore at least one last thing to worry about okay
oh i need a focus for this i hate this parkour.
This is such a rough parkour.
I feel like.
This parkour is pretty rough.
Oh.
All right.
Okay, I made it.
Get out of here.
Where does this lead me?
What is this?
Oh, I flee.
What's she doing here?
Gurb and bug not flee.
Why you must bother me?
This spot is mine!
Fear fought and gurn!
I won't stay long, madam, nor will I contest your right to this cave.
I'm kind of sober here, fellow fleas, united in a cavern.
Perhaps you consider joining with them.
Yes, Veer.
Veer seems a hardy hide.
I feel alone they lack the strength to survive long in this land.
Caravan, gurn, felt it in my fur.
Time for strange.
If Caravan is close, then my task.
These lands may near be complete.
Grr, much talk I give.
You leave me.
Meet again at Caravan amongst good fellows.
There I share my learnings of fleas and farloom.
Till then, rest I need.
Off bug.
That's it?
Sha-cha.
You still here?
Bug not flee.
Is rest I need before I leave for Caravan?
Not chat.
You feel trouble type.
Make my shell tense.
I shall take my leave, madam.
Stay trial on your own journey.
May we meet again a caravan.
Just because I'm murdered doesn't make me a bad person.
Alright.
Now head all the way to the right.
You mean the left?
That's my left.
Down I'll go.
Oh hey!
I'm back here.
Oh you mean the lake part.
Left then go right.
Oh, right on the map.
Okay.
Look, Sherma wanted love singing.
I just let her keep...
She was crying because of how much she loves singing, guys.
I was just giving her what he wanted.
Isn't that what Sherma wanted?
I hate these guys so much.
He just loved to sing.
Oh my god, I didn't realize that that was just it.
I thought I could just swim all the way through.
Oh shit!
Okay, right side.
Oh, it has a limit?
Oh yeah, what's the limit?
Hello?
What's over?
Oh, I thought that was a chair.
Guys, I don't know what's a chair and what's not a chair.
What's this?
Sisters spiders, watch these waters flow.
Lensing binding.
As a silk from shell.
Memories of our kingdom come.
Okay.
Swim, swim, swim, swim.
Oh my god.
I'm Michael Phelps.
Did I just swim right or did I go up?
Oh, decisions, decisions.
Actual clean water, yeah.
But there's nothing here.
That's it?
Oh, there's a craft metal.
Nice.
I know there's, like, stuff I can craft with it.
Oh, the little trinket thing.
We're done here?
Wait, so what's the point of being here?
Oh, it's for later use.
Okay, now go talk to it, please.
Okay.
Weeeeee!
Alright, we gotta go this way.
Oh my god.
Get away!
I'm back!
I hate this, Eric.
God thank God oh okay
I'm trying to be very careful right now because I don't
okay I'm scared I'm so scared I'm so paranoid I think you get I think you guys can tell that I'm so paranoid right now I think everything is a fucking vine that's willing that's wanting to eat me it's like they're all vines oops all vines I want to sit here just so I can have my back like
they're all it's like they're all none of this is real none of them are real vines that's
it yeah nature is so beautiful yeah
all right we go to the fleas all right I'm gonna use the bathroom I'll be right back guys
back I'm ready thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yeah I he's getting impatient he's like leave all
right hello please I brought another oh wait oh she doesn't don't live there I forgot the fucking left I forgot I moved them I was like hello please i am here they're in the goddamn blasted steps
okay they've been living there for so long i forgot i forgot that they moved
they were there for so long
is it here wait it's not here wait where do i go Wait, I'm at the slabs.
I actually went to the slabs.
Okay, this way.
Oh my god, I forgot the stupid runback for this area.
And then it's like...
Whoops.
Oopsie.
They're like...
I'm trying to remember if there's like any shortcuts that I can do.
There we go.
Hey, there they are.
Nice.
That was a nice run back.
Have you met her again?
Our burly new companion, Vogue!
Fresh return from a long time spent tracking.
We have met, flea master.
It gladdens me that I'm so strong a flea.
Exists as her.
Yours was a caravan.
Sully lacking for protection.
And I am too bound by my own tasks to provide for you.
But we would never impose so.
And now no matter, her scent may be strong.
Her taste for a brew of bottomless, but her skill is sharp.
If predators draw close, her talents provide much confidence to her caravan.
Honestly, you just said this guy.
This guy?
This?
this guy.
Like, he could just sit on him.
Bro, he's bigger than this flea.
The Saint Bernard.
The Saint Bernard is bigger than this flea.
Very greetings again, large flea.
Amongst all of your trope, I little doubt you have survived to reach this caravan.
Would you tell me now the texts that saw you so apart from your fellows and so fearsome in form?
Grr, bug not flee.
Mine is to track by trail and smell, and sense is sharp.
Find our flea friend fleas.
Our young, most of most, to bring them together and grow them strong.
If you have sense of location of utter lost fleas, share them with me.
I may be able to send them safe to the care bed.
My learnings?
Not free for you.
Bug not flee.
Rosaries.
Give those, and I shall save what I have since.
Work like mine.
long and hard.
And for that, I deserve some riches held.
Alright.
Um, we'll do the cheapest one.
I ain't made out money.
Wait, Bone Lands?
Uh, I mean, there's more in Bone Lands.
I swear to God, if if I pay $150 and there's nothing there, I swear to God.
Alright.
I have marked your map bug.
See the learnings of fleas lost across land.
If you are brave as told by fellow, please, seek them, save them.
Okay.
Alright.
Where are they?
Oh, there they are.
Oh my god!
There's so many.
Holy shit.
I have not been saving anything.
I did not realize how many I have forgotten.
How the fuck do I get this flea?
All right, now I'll grab more.
Oh, I can go off.
Yeah, I've not been saving shit.
Doors are off.
How many do I need, guys?
15?
How many do I need?
Seven?
Okay, one, two, three, four, five, six.
Guys, where's the seven?
Oh, seven.
okay is there an easier one anywhere
okay we'll grab one more somewhere you should say i mean it's a choice i'll grab this one too all right all right we'll go up to the bone lands first i want to be i want to we'll do the rest later I want to save the required amount For
The required amount To unlock Act 3 first
Alright, we gotta go Let's go down To the deep docks There's one at the deep docks Yeah, I'll do it before Act 3 because I hear the enemies Get a lot harder
okay wait how do i okay it's right here to the left i was like wait a minute okay that means there's a secret area yeah i know there's a secret room here oh my you weren't even in danger you were just sleeping bro he was just sleeping
oh my god
This kid wasn't even missing!
Oh, I can't do it.
I'm so sad.
I thought I could.
I just went in the shards.
Bro needed his nappy.
Whoops.
That was my bad.
I got curious.
I want to know what's over there.
What is over there?
Oh, nothing.
Oh, it was just in case you don't have double jump.
I know, wake up.
Oh!
Alright.
Oh boy, it's nothing.
Alright, where's the next one?
Next one is at the pilgrim's rest.
I assume for this it's here.
And, okay, I have to go here to grab it.
I figured.
Is it here?
Is it hidden or...
Guys, for this one?
Is it hidden or do I go here?
It is?
Okay.
It is here.
Barfields.
Okay.
Oh.
Grab the chair.
Just in case.
Go right?
One is right of the bell beast.
Oh, okay.
Like here?
Oh, it is here.
La- Oh.
I forgot about the...
Oh!
Also that.
Oh my god, these fuckers.
I will always hate you.
Oh my god, I will always hate you.
I feel like these guys have to be like run killers.
I feel like, I feel like a lot of people must have like lost their runs because of these fuckers.
It's so annoying.
More so like when you're flying, it's very annoying.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, I forgot about you.
What?
And like, I'm...
Oh my god.
That's annoying.
Alright, can I farm?
Yeah, I'm farming you for silk.
Oh my god, I need the wonder for this part.
Oh my god, I hate this poke!
Okay, I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna use...
I know what to do.
JK, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god!
Okay, wait, I know what to do.
I swear to god.
Okay, I need silk.
Okay, it's fine.
Guys, I know what to do.
I swear to God.
I know what to do.
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
We did.
I told you I knew what to do.
I told you.
Oh my god
I didn't lie I know what to do Oh my god
These guys tilt me so hard
Okay Down I go For one fucking dog Is he at least a good boy Silly jokie, they're all good boys
Oh There they are, sleeping, sleeping on the job Your parents are worried about you And you're sleeping, oh my god Can we go this way?
Wake up Oh There we go I don't know who that is But oh my god, it's him again Oh my god, it's fine.
I'll just kill him for the fun of it.
Oh.
Well, I hope there's no consequences for freeing him.
Um, I hope he doesn't go.
Oh.
Um, maybe we someone should check that village down.
Yeah, rest in peace.
Okay, rest.
surely he's not gonna terrorize the town right wait i broke the door do you think they're alive in there hold it up
it's fine we don't have to check we don't have to check it'll be fine it'll be fine No, it's okay.
It's okay.
If I never check, then I know they're safe.
If you never check, then you never know if they're safe or not.
I like to believe that they're safe.
Ignorance is bliss, you know.
door and release the beast uh
let's see there's like so many oh money
money all right we don't know that we don't know if they're dead or not it's like shrogyngers shrogyngers uh pilgrims we don't know if we never check the box we'll never know
Oh, bye.
It's like when you don't see any bodies and you don't know... Oh, there he is.
Okay, now see this...
See, he's trapped.
I'll just kill you for money.
See, look, that's a flea that needed to be saved.
Unlike the other fleas that were just fucking sleeping.
Oh yeah, oh there it is.
Now I'll kill you just for the sake of it.
Twend!
Now where am I?
Oh, okay we gotta go to...
Oh shit.
We gotta go this way.
Mass charge in the area I did not see.
Explore?
Which?
This one?
Where is it?
Oh, this?
I'll do that later.
I'll grab the other.
I won't grab the other one.
I want to grab all the...
Grab all the fleas for because I feel like the fleas are the most frustrating part in general because it's literally just a fetch quest
she's never returning is she no no I'll be back I'll be back I swear I'll be back guys and then she never came back
don't worry guys I'll be back I'll be back
Okay, the flea should be here, right?
Hello?
Does the flea live here?
Oh, shit.
It's here.
Oh, fuck!
Oh my god, I didn't bring the magma.
Oh god, it's so loud.
Oh no.
Oh, why didn't I bring the...
Why didn't I bring magma to the magma room?
That's right.
Is there like...
Wait, is there like a thing up here?
I just want to be sure.
Am I supposed to...
No, okay.
I wasn't sure.
Oh my god, yeah, there was.
That's where the flea is.
feel it I I fucked up I lost all my I didn't have enough silk I forgot to regen regen okay
all right this must be where he lives what are you fucking kids oh my god I set up the alarm how was I supposed to know they were guard how was I I didn't know fleas were that guarded.
Oh, okay.
At least...
Ring a ding-ding.
It's flea time.
Oh, I still had that, too.
Oh, yeah.
There you go.
Kabooey.
Why are fleas such value resources?
Oh.
All they do is just go...
You don't need, like, 20 guardsmen for one flea.
And, Debbie, and that's exactly why they're valued.
You need more than that.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Wait, I can just do it.
that way what the fuck am I doing oh shit I'm so sad I'm so sad oh I thought I was gonna make it I really did I'm so scared okay maybe what all right Okay.
It's Koran.
Ring a ding ding, ring a ding ding.
Ring a ding ding!
Jesus, I'm locked in!
Jesus, that's it.
I'm just gonna use my tools.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh, my praise.
It's so dark.
It's so dark, too.
I don't have poison.
I have to...
I don't have enough space for it.
I got tag team.
Oh, my God, went the wrong way.
There's so many things.
Just for one fucking dog.
Okay.
You don't understand, Doki.
It's the team dog.
Yeah,
I need him to go this way.
That's fine.
I can take that.
For one good boy.
Okay, ring ding ding ding ring ding ding.
Jesus, it's fine.
Okay.
Okay That's fine spam Nice Okay
God it's so loud too There we go Think okay, okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
I have the magma.
We should be fine Okay, I just spammed every... I spanned all my utail for that.
I just... I was like, chainsaw!
Chainsaw!
It never ended.
I preemptively chainsawed.
Also, thank you for the raid, Sally.
Thank you.
I got a good stream.
That's for the flee.
Yeah?
Where the fuck is the flee?
Random Bullshit, here we go.
Oh, you mean right.
Okay, you guys...
I should have just looked at the map.
Hello.
Wake up.
Oh!
Alright, go home.
Hey, where is this area?
Okay.
The other left.
Okay, I don't know what this is, I'm going down just to check it out.
Let's hang out.
Oh, there's nothing too dangerous, yeah?
Twin!
There you go.
Is there a mashard here?
I'll grab it.
Whoa!
He's doing facelifts on everything!
Oh, peace God.
Wait, that's it?
He just poofed away?
Just like that?
What does this do?
I go out!
I don't even know where he went!
What's this?
Ow.
I'm a little scared here.
There's this- Good world.
Oh.
Oh, shortcut.
Nice.
Oh, that's all.
Oh, oh.
They added some things in my shortcut.
Okay, actually, it's good that we have shards.
They added some slugs in my shortcut for some reason.
Okay, now we go this way.
There's another shortcut.
We're open.
How does this go?
Yeah, I ordered a churka with side of lava slugs.
Door?
Wait, have I been here before?
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, I have.
Why do I open this?
Wait, I haven't- I can't even open this.
We're... I'm so confused.
I'm so confused.
You did it, Toki.
You found the locked door.
Oh, it's the key.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Oh, it's that door.
All right, down I go, I guess.
Yeah, it's a locked thing I didn't open.
Oh lord Hey guys Oh Wait boss Oh my god Okay Okay Okay I didn't know I didn't
It's fine I don't know any of his attacks That's the thing I'm worried about No it sucks I have no tools
That sucks I actually have no tools so I am a little scared because of that oh
my god you fuckers it's fine we're okay why do you all have minions okay there you go it's fine friend
ALEE!
Okay.
That's fine.
God, I wish.
I- Oh my god, you fucker!
Oh my god, you fucker!
Okay.
This is- this is so stressful.
There you go.
That's fine.
that's fine that's fine okay good roll there you go one down
actual fucker how much how many gimmicks do you need how many gimmicks do you need you have a friend people and then you also have lava like you know what I only have I just have a needle that's all I have oh my god I almost I almost killed myself I I was like you know what I would do let me heal in front of the lava in the middle of the lava he has two attacks he needs to give me but wait there's more I was like You know what?
This fight isn't close enough.
Let me heal in the... Let me heal in the lava.
I did it.
I barely had my weapon.
What do you mean?
I came in there with, like, nothing.
Alright, nice.
Alright, we got the shortcut.
Oh, is this Asana?
Okay.
I just have the needle, a chainsaw, a boomerang, the ability to heal my wounds, and a charm that protects against fire.
Yeah, and?
Yeah, but he has lava.
It's not fair.
Yeah, but I didn't do call a friend.
Oh, my God.
At least I was a pussy and called a friend.
Oh, wait, that's a big slug.
Have you killed a big slug?
Ow.
I'm not sure.
I'm just gonna kill it just because I can.
When you don't know what to do, just kill it.
It just seemed dangerous.
I don't know.
Oh, my God.
Of course I died there.
Are you serious?
Wait, what's over to my left though?
Oh my god, his range is crazy.
Is there anything here?
No?
Oh, it's just absolutely nothing.
I love it when it's absolutely nothing.
Oh!
All right, okay, I deserve that.
That was very stupid.
Hey, what's over here?
Wait, there's like two secret areas, but which one is the secret area I have to go?
Okay, I didn't realize he was that thick.
There we go.
Okay, I deserve that.
I deserve that.
I have to go through all this goddamn slug skin.
Oh my god.
But like, what was the other secret?
You guys saw that other secret area, right?
I'm like a little confused.
Where does that go to?
I forgot about him.
I forgot about the spikes.
Oh, it's this!
Oh my god, I could grab that.
Oh, it was just a beast shard.
It's not even that important.
Wait, he's on!
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's fine Because I know we had this
God Boom,
all right boomerang boomerang boomerang Thank
God good roll that was actually so lucky Now where am I Did someone order more slugs?
Now where am I?
Hello?
Knock knock.
By an Ornid champ.
How do I open this?
What?
Oh, for later?
Oh, it's for area three.
Oh!
Or act three.
I was like, knock knock?
Anyone here?
Oh, I already thought I opened this already.
Okay, now we go.
Okay, I've been here.
I've been there.
We go to chair.
Jesus Christ.
I'm not happy about this place.
I need to figure out how to get out of here.
A broken wall.
I miss it?
Oh, here.
There it is.
Now where am I?
Down I'll go.
Down I go.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, memory lock it.
Anyone order more fire?
Please.
sir i'm so tired of all the fires sir i'm so tired i need to go use the sauna sauna time all right next flea next flea grab that uh where the fuck is the next flea okay here in great more And then How the fuck do I get this Fleet, chat?
Where do I go for this?
Finish the area?
I'm pretty sure if... Okay, there's that area, but I don't think that's that important.
The nook above here?
Is it here?
There's a tool there?
But is it a good tool?
I mean, I assume this is from here.
What's the tool?
Maybe.
Okay, guys.
Is it a yes or no answer?
Will I use the tool?
But is it a tool that I will use?
Perhaps.
A yesent.
Okay.
Probably not.
Tools are for collecting, not for using.
Alright, I guess we leave.
I guess there's no good tool.
There's nothing else I have to get.
So it's leaving time.
Oh my god, this stupid fucking platform.
It's a boost tool, like a range thing.
Hmm.
Alright, I'll go grab it.
Oh.
It's awkward.
Whop, alright.
That's...
That's awkward.
I forgot about that.
Ring, ring, ring.
Why did I talk to her?
How did you come to search?
of these dogs, Forge Doctor.
Hands from thy fraud, churning away, I request to those holy bugs above.
The Soda dwellers, the veiled bugs, they ordered you here?
Yes, and age ago that such is duty before its daughters lived to hone the craft and ain't the line.
I the Soda Thel's patronage and our long duty upon these dogs our Forge corn was swelling Holy esteem Oh nice, good for you Oh, I don't have anything to buy from here Oh Yeah, that's her voice I love That's actually her voice It's canon I love you Also,
like, you know how like she's such a big bug holding such tiny fucking tools Big baby, she's a big baby Ada!
Alright, Greymoor.
And thus it has become canon.
Yay!
Here we go, this way.
Okay, we gotta...
Well, I'll go up.
How to go up.
Up we go.
Wait, is there like an entrance here?
here?
I don't remember.
I don't think so.
Oh, we have to go on the other side.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god, not the scissors.
And then...
I'm still going up.
Where is this flea?
Oh my god.
He's sleeping.
How about get up there.
How are you just locked?
Oh my god.
Okay.
How do we get up there?
He's locked behind cage for his crimes.
The other side.
Where the fuck is the other side?
Go right and up.
Okay.
Okay here.
Alright, up I go.
Weeeee!
Did you miss this, right?
Why did I open?
Oh my god, I forgot he could do that.
I forgot this freak can do that.
Okay.
And then I'm up.
Weeeee!
Oh, I almost clutched that.
Okay.
Okay, get this, guys.
Oh, my God.
I forgot all these enemies that I fucking hated.
Oh, I need...
Oh, I do.
Oh, my God.
They're everywhere.
There's rats.
And spikes.
Everything is here.
Okay.
This flee better be worth it.
Where M?
Oh, it's over here.
Down I go.
Hello.
Wake up!
Next flea.
Okay, we got this flee.
Now we have to go here.
jump there for a secret area and a flea here wait what double jump where
here oh here
okay wait where am i whisp thicket where the fuck is this area what the fuck they have fire magic what the fuck oh my god who are these people Oh my god, they have wizards.
Okay, bench to the right.
Yeah, I think I need that bench.
Where are the benches?
Oh my god, I passed the bench.
I passed.
Oh my god, it was a bag.
What is a bench and what is in a bench?
Oh my god, it's right here.
It's right here.
The goddamn fireball.
Oh my, please tell me I can cut that.
I can cut it.
Oh, I hate these guys so much!
I'm leaving.
They win, he wins.
Oh, there's another.
Oh my god.
There's so many.
It ricochets.
Oh my god.
He's nice.
I actually stay.
Oh, the lanterns are break.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, now that's good.
Now that I know.
Oh my god, I hate them so much.
Okay, I am not gonna deal with it.
Fuck it.
Let me sit on the bench.
I don't want to lose my...
I don't want to lose it.
Oh.
Oh, God.
I broke it.
This area.
Okay, I'm leaving.
I don't need to be there.
I'm not here.
I don't need to prove anything.
Jesus Christ.
Why?
Oh,
I got it.
Oh, I got it.
I got.
Oh my god.
The maggots.
It's okay.
I got a mask, chart.
It's fine.
Okay.
I got rid of the maggots.
At least.
I'm leaving.
I go.
I leave.
They win.
This is their territory.
Alright.
They win.
Oh!
Keep going up?
Something up there?
What's up there?
Okay, but is it truly worth it?
How...
How worth it, guys?
I hate it.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
oh my god this is the final boss
goodbye it fucking crazy snipes me
this is the Yep, we're exploring not enough.
This is my, this is my final boss right here.
Oh my god, I hate top fucking kill average.
Why is there so many fire?
Fire truly is bad.
Oh my god, I don't care if I die.
I had to get that.
No, you don't understand.
I don't care.
I had, I had to.
Oh my god.
No,
not again!
I'm gonna crash out.
Oh my god.
Let's see, I got it.
I got it.
It's a bone scroll.
Oh, for a bone scroll, it's not.
It was on.
It's okay, I'm closer.
I'm closer right now.
I'm closer.
Just for a bone scroll.
Oh my god, I'm not okay.
I just, I was, that's it.
That's it.
It has to die.
Okay.
There we go.
It's okay.
We can slowly get back down now.
We're fine.
Okay, this way.
It's fine.
I just need to get past him.
Okay.
down here.
Oh, it's just water.
I mean, that's nice.
Maybe I'll be free.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Oh, there's craft metal in one of the balloons.
We'll come back for it.
We'll come back.
Surely.
Oh.
Hello.
Guys, I don't think we're coming back oh father of nothing how oh my god oh
i'm literally just fighting fire
i'm just fighting fire i'm fighting my inner demons right now
This sucks.
This sucks so much.
Got your arm!
That's fine.
Okay.
How the fuck do I get over there?
Holy shit!
What kind of parkour do I have to do?
Wait, what?
Oh, I have to harpoon.
Yeah, I was like, how do I?
Oh, my God.
This sucks.
Oh, oh, my God.
I have to, like, slow and steady.
Are you serious?
Oh, Oh my god, I couldn't win.
Oh my god, you son!
I swear to god, I swear to god.
There we go, there we go.
Oh, he's still angry.
He's still going?
Holy, holy shit.
oh
my god he's so angry he's so angry
i wish guys i'm getting the wonder i'm getting i'm swapping chris i'm swapping chris now i can't i can't do the hunter on this that was absolutely hell.
That was hell right there.
Grab this too.
Wait, what is?
Alright.
I was not ready for it.
Okay.
So which one has the Oh, right here.
That's fine.
I'm just grabbing this.
Oh my god, it was just...
It was just fucking...
That was nothing.
Yeah.
There's so many of you.
Okay.
Alright.
It's time.
Oh, he forces me.
Oh, I could have.
Okay.
There we go.
Wow, this feels a lot easier now.
Who would have thought?
I wish I did that sooner.
Way easy.
Oh, fuck it.
There you go.
Oh my, there you go.
It's easy.
Laugh live the Pokemon.
Who would have thought?
The Whispire Lantern.
Oh my god, where the fuck is the flea?
No more fight.
How do I even...
Congratulations, he got one of the wish...
I came here for the flea!
Where is he?
Oh, he's in the bag of rosary.
Okay.
I was gonna... I was like, where the fuck...
You don't have firepower anymore.
Wait, he just became fire.
What happened?
I was like, haha, I got you now.
And he's gone forever.
Okay, but this still works though.
Like fuck me.
Okay, this still works.
Okay, this should not still work though.
Oh god, I'm hitting by my...
I'm actually hitting by my thread right now.
Oh, right here.
By my silk thread.
Haha!
Okay.
Oh, yo.
I would like my craft metal.
Alright, so where is...
Break wall on the left?
Like far left?
Just want to be sure in case you guys got confused where left is.
I wanted to be sure.
Oh, this one.
I wasn't sure.
See, some of you guys might be directionally challenged.
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
All right, let's go back.
Where is that?
Oh my god, okay, whatever.
There you go.
Where's my fucking silk?
Why is it over here?
Cren.
All right.
Use a little fucker.
This is this way?
Wait, what?
What's down here, though?
Yeah, I can see it.
There's something here.
Oh, it's just shards.
That's fine.
I need shards anyway.
Just fine.
Alright.
We're still trying to find this one flea.
Wherever he is.
Oh my god, you know.
Oh my god, no.
Okay.
Um, I need a...
What am I looking at?
I was trying to dash.
Oh, I still made it.
Speedrun.
I don't know.
I'm so scared.
I wonder what happened.
Now I found real hell.
Oh god, this runback fucking sucked.
You know what's even worse?
I feel like there's a fleet that's easier to get than doing this.
There must be a fleet that is easier to get than this fucker.
Oh.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Okay.
I don't remember how I did this.
Will you not die for him?
Okay.
I hesitated.
I fucking hesitated.
I hesitated again.
Oh my god, I hear him.
Get out of here, you fat fuck.
Oh my god.
You goddamn fat fuck.
Just kill him because I can.
And I need this.
Door open.
Okay, now where am I?
Now where is this place?
What the fuck?
What is this place for?
What?
A shortcut to where?
Oh, this!
I was like, where is this leading me to?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, there we go.
I was so confused.
Oh, wait, am I in a citadel?
Wait, I am.
I'm at the underworks.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm back in super capitalism.
Alright, I got all the fleas there.
Okay, we still need that fleas.
So I didn't go back to Graymore.
And after that...
Wait, how many fleas am I missing?
Chat.
How many more do I need to get?
Someone said I had, like, four more?
Okay, that's doable.
Door open.
Okay.
I'll grab the elevator.
elevator all right elevator grand bellwig gray more yeah but i only need like 25 apparently
all right mark that down hey so
i'll grab what was it gray more i just need four more and then we have all the required please you can technically enter act two through whisper the thing again you just have to form a bunch of ridiculous difficult platform skills to get double jump and act one without harpoon jesus christ why would you do that to yourself like like why oh okay let's just use one here for now
okay this way Everyone said I just need 25, so I choose to believe them.
Yeah, but I want to grab the minimum requirement first, and then we can...
Okay, I need...
And then we'll look at grabbing all the fleas later.
I just want to grab the minimum requirement for Act 3 before we do another stream.
It's just like a goal before I end stream today.
Alright.
Wait, how do I get to this corner?
So how do I get this flea here?
Is it through this door?
Oh, it's this door.
Come on.
Hey, who's that?
Hello?
Oh, wait, there's a flea!
Wait, there's a grown-up dog!
You're not a dog?
Who are you?
What a turn for a dear crowd to be strung up in such a dark little thing.
little cave.
Curse threads stretched throughout the land, such as shared unwearied.
You seem no worse for now at least.
That metal carriage, it is yours, I assume.
Yes, yes.
I'm setting out to join the nearest flea caravan, aren't I?
Safety in numbers, yes.
I'm more than enough of venturing alone.
And you, I trust I will see you there.
My carriage hides a special secret.
I'll gladly share with you when we next meet.
I'm getting some creepy vibes off of him.
He even has, like, the creep mustache, you know?
He has that creepy mustache.
Good luck, my dear.
My carriage.
Okay.
Alright.
I guess we go now.
Yeah, he feels a little creepy.
The way he said that.
And he's, like, rubbing his hands, too.
Like, that's just full-on.
like, creep behavior.
I don't know if I want to I don't want to know if I want his like special carriage gift He looks a little sussy.
Yeah He's like oh don't worry.
I have a special little gift for you in my carriage It's painted white.
It's like my white carriage
You want his special gift do I do I really
Oh, I won't change this back to...
Actually, we'll grab that for now.
Well, we can change back to our normal crest.
Unless...
I don't think we have any more Pogo's.
Right?
Right, guys?
Oh, and I could get rid of this too.
I don't think we need magma anymore.
Oh, this way.
I don't think we have any more.
Yay!
Well, this runback is so easy now.
Hello, oh god.
He's ready.
Alright, hello.
Greetings again, Sir Fleet.
I see you're able to unite safely with this caravan.
Oh, yes, all thanks to you, dear sweet you.
The Lee Master that old word tells me to call you, Miss Hornet.
But such a prickly name, Milbiff, has such a delicate beauty.
shall I call you something prettier like nectar sweet my dear you shall not address me by my name or not at all oh grad back of course of course and now I shall let you on my little secret my courage doubles as a soothing spa you see it's most ingenious the water inside is piping hot and pure than Osam.
I'll gladly let you soak inside for a modest fee.
And, I mean, all my muscles do need to relax.
Alright, fine.
One time.
I want to see what the spa is like.
Also, it's fucking weird that his carriage is a fucking spa.
Like, I feel like that's, I don't know.
That's a little creepy.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll treasure these sweet, smelling trees dearly now don't be shy step inside
he's like oh yes get into the spot i what is he gonna do with my bath water
what do you hear that what was that
Hmm.
Oh.
Zero and Dasha.
Have your turn to use...
Oh.
I have to hit him when I'm there.
Okay.
I thought I had to go outside and hit him.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
I gave him another $10.
Ooh!
Oh!
Damn, he's fast.
Why is he so fast?
There we go.
Get out of here.
What is he?
I know!
What is he even staring at?
Like, it's just... It's just my... Oh my gosh, she's showing her neck.
Whoa!
That's right.
Okay, it's such a very over-mistake.
Just one mistake.
Poor little cat.
Did I mean to steal a look?
I didn't mean to steal a look five times.
This old carriage needs constant care.
I was only doing repairs.
I had no intent to intrude And I barely saw a thing Fly no more to me flee And be grateful you still live Know that I appear again, you will die Grat will never Consider the matter forgotten And shall forever be my treasure guest That's working right Get out of here,
give me that chair Alright Oh wait, I can hit him again That's right Get away from you, perfect That's right, wait, is he Wait, look at the... Look at the...
Look at the...
His eyes before he touches the ground.
He's... He's smiling.
He enjoys it.
Look at that.
Get out of your pervert!
Get out!
That's right!
You gotta pay...
You gotta pay for it!
He's like, you want map?
I can play a little volleyball too.
Woo!
Volleyball!
I can juggle this.
Alright.
Beach Volleyball.
Alright, I figured out where to go now.
Wee!
Alright, let's go to the tram.
And then...
we gotta figure out where the next flea is.
Chair.
Oh, wait.
That's the tram.
Wait, actually?
Wait, I actually want to see.
Okay, where is it?
Okay.
One of my friends told me to check this out.
There's a hidden wall here somewhere.
Where is it?
Is it down here or is it up here?
Oh, it's here.
Bug boy in a far loom.
you have been chosen mercedo's holy gliding heart in your soft shell sound eternal as our arbiter there's no bug bearing sin shall step within our sacred hall down here
hello oh
this is dad this is dad when he's like it's time for food
whying over oh we're my wall go?
How do I get up?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh, okay, here.
I was a little worried.
I was worried that I'd be trapped with a wasp for the rest of my life.
It's the song of our people.
Cheers.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What was that room for?
Woo!
wow it's for art down here there you go would you like a wow or a wow it's a performance that's what the it's a wow room exactly it's the wow room like how many fleas do I need now chat is anyone has anyone been keeping count
alright the citadel Okay, Coral Chambers.
I've taken over here.
Oh, yeah, I did go to the shop.
The thieves, right?
One or two?
Okay, so it's these two.
Let's see.
I'm just checking, like, where to go.
I'm going to wrap here and then from here.
Okay.
How do I get this one?
Is it from here?
I assume it's here, right?
All right, I gotta take the elevator and get here.
All right.
Tram time.
Ada!
From left bottom.
Okay, let's grab the elevator and then we'll figure it out.
Chair time.
Eye hauls.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Chaitab.
Okay.
Let's figure this out.
This wall?
Or here?
Left wall here?
On this side?
Dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey, dokey.
This is when I'm getting backseated.
Right here.
Doki, listen!
I hate this area.
Wait, what?
How far away is it?
Just down?
I think it looks breakable.
Oh, there it is.
There is that breakable.
I was like, nothing looks breakable.
And then there's a crack right here.
Are you serious?
How the fuck?
How the...
How?
Down still?
Oh, I did another breakable.
Oh, okay.
I was a little worried there.
Oh, there it is.
I was like, what am I supposed to do?
Okay, there we go.
I was very worried.
Oh, I can't.
I thought I would open that door too.
Oh my god to do this again.
Thank god he died.
Wake up!
Oh!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, this one's an easy one at least.
Alright.
I wonder if I can... fuck.
Okay.
I'm gonna try.
Okay, yeah, I can still do that.
Thank God.
Uh, hi-haus.
Oh!
Apparently, everyone uses the Wanderer for, like, speedruns, because it's, like, the fastest.
But, like, I don't know.
I'm already so used to the Hunter, Chris.
I'm just gonna use what I'm comfortable with for now.
And then down here and up.
Okay.
Wait, did I go the wrong elevator?
I did.
No, I didn't.
Okay, down.
Uh...
Yeah, oh, and the crit.
Yeah, I forgot about the crit, too.
Oh, these marvelous...
Oh, you're still talking about the supplies.
Oh, new wish?
Oh, new wish!
Horrible cries have been heard from the prison beside the citadel.
What propanities must be happening within to cause such awful noises?
All right, so there's something at the citadel.
Our near mission left to scavenge treasures from them.
All right.
What's at the slab?
Do these next stream?
They're hard.
All right, we'll just do...
We'll focus on the fleas then.
I want to just grab...
Do as many, like, quests as I can.
Before we go into...
No, I want to kill you.
them, just because I don't care.
Give me your money.
Okay, this way.
Down.
Alright.
Here we go.
Wait, why do I have to go to this lab?
Gotta figure out.
Not hard quest?
Now where do we go?
Where the fuck is...
Oh!
Where is he?
Did I have to move this?
Up, right?
Oh, I have to move that box.
Okay.
Yeah, I was like, where the fuck is he?
Alright, goodbye box.
Oh my god, I have to move all of this back here.
Okay, and then we move it from here.
Up it goes.
All right.
Oh, there's a bat here.
Wait, but where is it?
Oh, shit!
Come on, get over here.
That's right, get out of here.
Now what?
Oh, it's on the right side.
Oh, there he is.
Alright.
Be free, child.
Oh!
Nice.
I'm a hero.
Alright.
That should be all the fleas.
Because we counted.
Yeah.
Because I...
Oh.
Fuck.
Okay.
I'm gonna check with the...
We'll leave him locked up for now.
Don't.
Don't worry.
We saved the minimum amount.
It's like that Jordan Peele skit where he's like, would you like to donate a daughter to save a child?
And I'm like, all right, we saved enough children.
Go, go, go.
We saved enough kids.
It's fine.
Okay, Belle.
And then...
A bare minimum achieved.
Sorry, I only donated enough to save eight kids.
Okay, they're bad parents if they let 30 fleas.
They let 30 fleas go missing.
They're the ones that are bad, bad parents.
Wee.
Alright, let's check if we got enough.
Yeah, how do you lose?
30.
One is like triple the size of a regular flea.
Like at this point, I feel like we're just abducting children for your caravan.
How do we even know they're your kids?
Okay.
Home is the horned cornet.
Wonder how large our caravan has grown so bold and bolstrous.
This gilded chamber can barely conduct can need us all the many fleas are itching to journey once more to find a space to stretch their wings but from here as their leader I'm hesitant to order us so swiftly away these heights hold too much danger to set forth who has safe gold held clear in mind what of you miss hornet your task carries you throughout this kingdom have we encountered a place a place appropriate I have seen a place for the master a cave beyond the citadel at the edge of the some ancient suit your needs for safety that trek will be long but once reached you'll find a sandy shore free of predators beside a wide clear lake it is as peaceful a place as seen throughout these fraught lands that's it it must be our destination has been said our journey can continue true friend the fleas you are miss hornet that place shall welcome us no doubt will you be joining the caravan on this journey?
Yes.
I want to be in the dog car.
Marvelous!
Wefully shall be overjoyed to have your company on the road.
Now our new home is calling.
We must travel!
What a wonderful place.
Perch of petrified ducks.
Oh my god, there's so many now.
There's so many.
I think we need two cars.
Oh!
My entire cloak is just flea hair now.
Oh, the beautiful spot you've gifted us, Miss Hornet.
Safe apart from a dark and deaf with the lands beside.
A place for fleas to grow strong and smart.
Here we shall see our travels end.
For in Farloom, there can be no finer place to settle.
I am glad the location suits, Flea Master.
calming thing to know that many fleas may survive.
Most bugs of fire looms seem destined for far bleaker fates.
Indeed, a hopeful future awaits, and only because of yourself and your efforts.
To commemorate our arrival, it would be my pleasure to perform a small service for you.
I have been learning to sue.
So, and the little fleas have been gathering materials for me.
I thought I'd add an extra pocket for your tool pouch to make your travel a little easier.
A trifling flavor, So, I hope it meets your satisfaction.
Tool upgrade.
Leetopia.
Oh my god.
I have founded a new land.
And I shall cut.
Oh my god.
It's so far away from any fucking cars.
Oh my.
Why?
Why would you settle in petrified docks?
It's so far.
I'm angry now.
I'm mad.
This is a terrible place.
This is...
This place is actually terrible.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is this area?
Alright, I just want to be sure.
One, two.
Oh shit.
No fuck.
Oh fuck.
All right, we'll worry about that.
We'll let future Doki handle that.
I gotta figure out how to get home.
Oh!
Future Doki needs to figure out where home is.
Is it easier to go from up?
Oh, we'll try up first.
Fuck it.
If I die, oh, I was gonna sit.
All right.
Guys, what quest can we do next?
I'll do like one more quest and then we'll call it here.
The slab?
What's the slab quest?
That's fine.
It's no longer fine.
Yeah, I'm gonna heal.
Meet Shak- I'm not meeting Shak- I'm not going up.
any quest but guys any quest but anything near the bile water the slab yeah but is that quest though it's the roof area okay but like
which isn't okay one easy quest one easy quest guys this one
Is it actually really easy?
Is it...
Apparently the merchant is easier.
What the fuck?
Who's crying?
All right.
We'll fight a boss.
Okay, we'll fight a boss.
I don't mind fighting a boss.
I won't end it with a boss fight anyway.
Can't be that bad.
My famous final words.
It can't be.
Oh.
It's at the bench.
Here?
How do I get up there, though?
It won't let me.
Oh, never mind.
I got it.
Wake up.
Oh.
Okay, this one was an easy flea to get.
Thank God.
Is that the wailing mother?
What even is my quest for this?
I did not read it fully.
Oh, it is.
Ooh.
All right, here it is.
How do I find?
him.
8th of the 12th.
Guilty of the sinner in Revan's.
Penance by chaining.
Absolute granted.
Pentium 2nd of the 4th.
Guilty of...
Oh, they're just like prison thing.
Okay, this has to be a lore.
Lore room.
Oh!
Oh, go back to where I snapped that dude's neck.
I actually don't remember.
I don't remember where I snapped your net his neck jump at jump up at the lower in the left room oh yeah oh I see it secret what's here oh I knew it secret secret oh memory lock it okay we have to unlock some shit oh my god someone Please stop her.
I got here.
Where did I snap her?
His neck.
Is it here?
Oh, I think it was here.
Did I snap it here?
No.
Oh, up?
Oh, my God.
I just missed the trap.
Second bench from the top.
Oh, okay.
Really?
I can't just go up from there.
Wait, then what the fuck did I unlock?
Oh, there it is.
What did I unlock?
Alright, that's good that there's a bench here.
Okay, she's here.
She's not here?
Oh.
Hello.
Oh, my.
Okay, thank god.
I think oh my god
Okay, okay they explode that's good to know That's good to know I'm glad that Oh god, oh god
Yeah All right big mom All right, the brood mother I don't know what you do.
Okay, you shoot.
Oh my god.
She's so chunky.
Oh god, she shoot kids.
She uses her kids as weapons.
Holy shit.
Oh, get it off me.
Get it off me.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, get it off me, get it off me, get it off me, get it off
Okay, well at least, okay, so I don't know, I don't like her It was not fun at all What I've learned was that that was absolutely not fun Oh my god, it's like a dynamite, it's like And then two, I don't think they're supposed to be fun.
Jesus.
Alright.
What?
Oh, Jesus.
Oh.
Oh My god, stupid fucking fly Oh, get it up and get it up and get it up and get it up and Are you so good ass?
Fat fucking ass He's fucking me over All right, we're changing weapons I don't think this is good.
I think I'm going to try.
Maybe this.
I don't have enough.
Her combos are so annoying.
Let's grab this then.
Craft a little.
Maybe.
Uh.
Let's see.
Yeah, I'm going to grab the explosive.
Okay.
What if I just...
Oops.
Okay, wait.
Yeah, I think this would be good.
Maybe.
Okay, at least there's friendly fire too.
That's good.
There you go.
There's friendly fire.
That doesn't do shit!
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad I thought it's okay okay that's fine
okay oh my god not I hate that move so much
that move is so scary no no no no no that move is I don't know I don't know okay
Oh my god!
God damn it!
There we go.
Jesus!
I just had to spout.
Oh my god, those poison bombs were so good.
The poison bombs were actually so clutch.
Nice.
Brood Mother's Eye.
That's right.
Finally, we've rid the world of flies.
We did it the reptilian population might go extinct but we did it it's not about them it's not about them it's about me finally we did it boys they are now forever extinct it was for a good cause yeah the reason why like we could technically exterminate all mosquitoes but we shouldn't because It'll destroy the entire ecosystem.
But we don't care about that.
Who cares about that?
All the bugs are gone.
The flies are gone.
A necessary evil must be eliminated.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's here.
Did I go too far?
I went too far.
Where am I?
Wait, what is this area?
Guys, I don't know where I am.
I went too far.
Oh my god, I did not mean to be here.
Okay, nice.
Weaver effigy.
The fuck is that?
Is that another...
Oh, it's something to give.
I dug too deep.
Now I don't know where I am.
out of here okay is there like an exit here it's
over here oh it's just money no exit we just go where am i where did where am i though so now that i'm here What?
Where is this place?
I'm so confused.
I'm so lost.
And now we're up here.
Hello?
Oh, shit.
I'm in a thieves' room.
Oh, my money.
Ha, jokes on him.
I didn't have a lot of money.
I spent it all.
Okay, now I'm here.
Oh, oh, shortcut.
Oh!
That makes sense.
Yeah, that's right.
Jokes on them.
I was already broke.
Okay, now I'm here.
I thought this area would lead me to the bench, but I guess not.
That's fine.
I just want to kill him anyway.
I'll deal with him from here.
Wait, where did I have to go?
Is there anything else I have to do here?
What's in?
Alright.
Oh my god, I forgot the freaks!
I forgot about these people.
Oh my god, the freaky...
Freaky prisoner at ex-guard roleplay.
It's the BBB enjoyers.
There's a hidden boss.
How hard is he?
Alright, I'll do one more boss, because that boss was not as hard as I thought.
I'll do one more.
Decently hard.
Okay.
What's... Okay, I'll see it.
I'll look at it.
I'll look at it and see how I feel.
Is it this one?
Is it here?
Okay, I did not enjoy the widow fight.
I absolutely did not enjoy the widow fight.
Below.
The lore signs.
I don't even remember where the lore signs was.
Is it here?
Here?
Oh, right below it.
Here.
Okay.
Alright.
I'll see how I feel.
I forgot, like, I can't do anything on the set.
Alright, we'll see how this boss feels.
Actually, uh...
We're gonna do that.
I'm gonna replenish my shards.
Alright, guys.
Is the boss...
A flying boss or a...
Ground boss?
Because, like, not flying.
Okay, I'll grab chain.
I'm gonna grab chainsaws then.
I'll grab my saws.
The wheel.
The ground type.
Okay.
We'll see how I feel.
We'll check it out.
Okay, you guys know I hated the widow boss, so...
Like, the widow was actually my kryptonite.
What the fuck?
Bro, I'm...
He was like slowly flying over to me.
I'm like, what the fuck?
Alright, that is money.
Yay, money!
All that money!
Employees only!
How do I get that?
Oh, there he is.
Okay, assume the hidden boss is here.
all right here he is oh not here he is oh my god it's a fucking maze of course it is
okay i assume it's this i assume he's locked up for for a reason all right time to free the prisoner it's time to do a very good thing surely it wasn't in prison for anything serious right
All right.
Oh, enter?
Oh, he lives here.
I have freed you.
I'm a hero.
Oh, it's a weaver.
Hello.
Half spawn of a distant land.
Within this cage I have waited.
Let my strength be bound to yours.
Reclaim the future of our ancestral kingdom.
I freed you.
You can be friends now, right?
Oh.
Friend?
Oh my god!
Oh my!
I'm just...
Like, I...
Okay.
I'm so...
I'm so confused.
What's that?
What is that?
Wait, why did she find?
Oh
No, oh I thought wait is there a bench nearby She's healing Guys I lost all my tools
Oh my god All right, he'll go again Guess no more tools.
Who needs tools?
Am I right?
She made herself a nice dress, you know?
Jesus Christ.
She's so fast.
Oh my god.
Let me just use up all my tools again.
Jesus Christ, can I hit her?
Am I...
okay I stopped her from hitting thank god oh my god
bro it's so hard it's so hard to hit her no
she's so fast
this is fucked up this is so fucked up it's so fast let me hit you
this is so fast I have no tools.
I have to use the dash and...
Oh my god.
Now I have no tools.
Kit.
I'm... I hate you.
I...
Oh, but...
I'm like worried of like like running into her.
That's what I'm worried about That's right.
Oh god good roll
Please Oh god, oh
Nice oh not nice
Oh I don't even know if I'm like get close.
I don't even know how many phases she has
Okay Okay
Oh my...
I...
This is actually...
It's so painful.
At least I have...
Friend!
Oh, that's unlucky for me.
Are you serious?
Where can we teleport?
Holy fuck.
Okay, her attacks are like...
Her pattern's easy, but it's also like...
Like, not easy, but like...
I can sense her pattern, but she's so fast.
She's just so fast.
Okay.
That's like my only...
The hardest part about her.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh my god, I feel that.
God damn it, I didn't think.
Oh my god.
I thought I could.
Are you serious?
Oh, that's so unlucky for me.
That's actually so...
Oh my god, good roll
Oh my god, that was so close I'm getting, I'm figuring her out though Okay, I'm hard focusing I'm hard focusing Oh my god, I think she should have been prison forever Why did I free her?
I met up, I fucked up by freeing her Now I know why
Are you serious?
Jesus.
Okay.
Nice.
For me?
Are you serious?
Of course she uses a dash now.
All right.
Nice, I canceled in time.
Oh,
I didn't see the other...
God damn it.
I thought I canceled in time!
Fuck!
Okay.
That was my bad.
No.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, he knocked me up in the air.
Oh, he knocked me up.
That sucked.
I just got the heal and then he knocked me into his hitbox.
No, I just got it.
I just got the heal.
I didn't have it yet.
Okay.
Oh my god, fucking course.
Yeah.
There you go.
Okay.
I'm just gonna heal here.
Oh my god, did he get it?
I can't tell.
I don't know.
I don't know if he got to heal.
Are you serious?
Nice.
there you go oh my god okay that was my bad
okay got the heal off oh nice oh my god he clawed
okay oh that wasn't that i oh my god i like i doubt oh what Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, what do you beat?
What do you beat?
Okay.
Oh,
I'm clicking first.
Okay.
I don't know.
Jesus Christ Okay I'm so sad I'm so sad I Oh Oh that was so close That was so close I got ricocheted back When I left my Harpoon I think I did really well too For it
okay okay all right oh my god fucking course i i need to remember like sometimes she does that she does that there you go
really okay i would really need to heals though.
Oh my god!
I ran the wrong way.
Yes!
I got it!
Oh, and she got me, though.
There you go.
Spread.
Okay.
Are you...
Are you serious?
Okay.
There we go.
Oh.
I need to remember when she does that.
There we go.
I think she got bugged there.
Thank you.
Thank God.
Oh.
Oh no, that's not good.
Let me.
I need that cool I'm max focus right now
nice oh that's so lucky oh
my gosh thank guy oh is there another face there's another face please don't tell oh my god thank god oh I don't know oh my god no no oh thank god okay oh there it is did I do it new skill oh my god i did it oh we're a skill update for how fucking hard she was
oh my god where am i where the fuck am i holy she i was so focused for that fight
fuck i was so focused i had zero tools too that was the i think the worst part was the fact that i had no tools for it i
died oh goodbye into the pit i go
Oh my god How the fuck was I supposed to know I can't see jack shit right now
Okay up I go After killing this fucking boss It forced me to do more parkour That's so messed up What?
I don't even know how long it took me I feel like it was a lot faster
Let's Oh.
It was not left.
Where in the...
I'm scared.
Oh, it's over here.
Okay, there we go.
Ah!
Oh my god, I just want your skill.
Do you have to put me in a fucking maze?
Yeah, let's try then.
When someone was like, used a harpoon, it like, licked in my head.
My reward for beating this boss is more parkour!
Yay!
Yeah, I heard like...
Oh, hey.
Oh?
Oh, it's Laura.
The silk evolved the spider.
Oh, it evolved the tiny little spider.
Wait, that's who I was?
Reward, Lord.
She called us daughters.
Call us to fight.
She lied.
Oh!
So the weavers came from silk.
They got evolved, just like how my dad evolved the other citizens.
Waves.
Weavers.
Wraith runes of blazing silk upon enemies.
Silk skills can be...
Okay, cool.
Cool.
It's like the monkeys when they hit the monolith.
Assume they gave it up.
What the fuck does this do?
Is this a circle attack?
Oh, the explosion thing?
Oh.
Yeah, that's RNG as hell.
Fuck that shit.
I'm leaving.
Yeah, that shit never hit me.
Other than that one time.
Yep.
Look at how it didn't even hit him.
Yeah, that room sucks.
It hit everything but him.
Oh my god, let's see.
Haha, I killed your lover.
Now I hope you live a long life knowing that I killed the love of your life.
Oh wait, he also died.
Never mind.
It got him too.
Let's see.
Oh, my God.
We'll call it here.
Oh, wow.
That was...
I don't know if I would...
I mean, I guess it was fun.
I think when I learned how to use the harpoon, the fact that I didn't even use tools for it, when I beat her, I think when I learned...
I don't know if she was bugged or like...
Because on the run that I beat her, she stood still.
But I think it's because, like...
Like, um, I guess it was like, uh, uh, I don't know.
Was he supposed to stand still when that was going on?
No, she just does that.
Oh, it was just good RNG.
Oh, I got really rare.
Yeah, she did that like three times.
Yeah.
I had really, really good RNG because all I did was just, I just used the harpoon over and over again.
But, um, but after when whoever was like used a harpoon on, they like everything just clicked because her patterns were easy Her patterns were really easy to figure out Um, but like it was just she was so fucking fast.
That was it.
She was just so fast.
So like I had the The moment I used a harpoon like everything just was very smooth for me.
Yeah.
Uh, but yeah, that was really fun we made a lot of progress uh uh today we first tried a lot of bosses today actually today we were actually gaming really well really hard uh a lot of bosses other than late I think the only boss um that was very hard was just lace too uh and we got the first ending we'll make more progress in trying to get act 3 next stream um but yeah thank you everybody for watching I love fun um I wish I could stream more,
but tomorrow's going to be a long day, too, and I don't want to fuck up my voice too much.
I already did, like, six hours, day.
Wait, is this six hours?
Six, seven, eight, nine, ten, yeah, six hours.
I did a six-hour stream the day, but honestly, like, Silk Song, I don't know, like, when I play Silk Song, like, the hours pass by so fast.
And, yeah, we first tried Savage Beast Fly, so we get to watch someone eat a shoe today.
Or not today, soon.
But anyway, guys, thank y'all for watching.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching me as well.
Um, and I always have a fun time stream for you guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and we're around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.